[Music]
hey hey Happy Thanksgiving no we did
different ones ah gobble gobble [ __ ]
here we go double gobbles a peeve
I'm ready with the peep I got a peep
already I don't like gobble gobble okay
what are you saying on gobble gobble um
I to be honest I don't think I've heard
anyone use it so freely until right now
oh I should have seen my ex
all right well you guys can both get
stuffed
I have yesterday yeah I think he wanted
to yeah yeah well we're joined by one of
our good buddies a comic we love give it
up Mateo Lane hey Happy Thanksgiving
Happy Birthday Thanksgiving yes yes
thank you not related to Nathan no but
um someone said to me at a restaurant
the other week this waiter comes like
I'm such a huge fan of your work I love
you Nathan Lane and I said you know what
I said that's wrong but honestly it's
right yeah and then he said then he gave
me a discount he was like but sorry for
messing up your name it's the Nathan
Lane discount I was like okay work day
wow I love Nathan Lane I'll take uh
Legends
one of the best movies of all huge time
take that Bros
all right I'm just kidding well how
about uh dude Guys and Dolls he's isn't
he Nathan Detroit and Guys and Dolls I
know he's in the producers he's new Guys
and Dolls as well Guys and Dolls from
like the 50s with yeah they did a redo
with Nathan Lane oh they did yeah Guys
and Dolls because he's got that very I
can see what's happening yeah I haven't
got a clue oh wow now I'm gay that's all
it takes I switch seats I want some of
that all right boys it won't help your
career apparents
later sorry that was off Mike I know if
I was straight I would have already won
an Oscar really I'm teasing speaking of
twinks can you hand me a Twinkie yeah
thank you these are not shaped like
Twinkies wait wait are those are they
pumpkin spice Twinkies I don't know oh
hey by the way and soda we tried these
for you they hated them I thought it was
decent no I like this I like the normal
Sweet Tarts these are awful and nerd
ropes are great right so don't try and
come for nerd roads and be like sweet
tart robes grow up are these pumpkin
Twinkies no I'll tell you right now but
they don't look like it
I don't know I don't like Twinkies I did
try the pumpkin Oreo and it was very
good Oreo's getting cocky oh Oreos
everywhere it's like Oreos really what
are they doing I saw Minto they're like
the pop heads Oreos are now like the pop
heads of flavor it's just like do you
know talking about those like pop heads
with like every character is like one of
those pop head action figures am I the
only nerd here okay sorry this reference
is not no I know it's very Asian it's
like a Japanese thing yes yes it almost
looks like a Hello Kitty but it's like
it could be anything like X-Men or like
those are cute they're very cute yeah
two fans make me them and I'm very easy
to do because I'm just Freddie Mercury's
head and Storms remember we did like a
roast battle thing on it never aired it
was on crashing why didn't they hear
that they didn't air it no and then I'm
still credited for crashing I was like
they took me and Sam out by the way they
said they said we had to cut you for
time I'm like it's HBO there's no
commercials that's a great point and
then uh so one of my lines in Mateo was
you look like you got Freddie Mercury
poisoning and you were skinnier though I
know before you were jacked so that's
why I had all my muscles now you're
shredded that's a great job and you ran
those by me and I was like these are
great you're gonna kill it I forget what
my jokes were dude some good ones you'd
want about like I'm not a good roaster
you were good it was funny you had
something on me about like it was
something like uh Sam loves basketball
and you can tell cause uh he's tall his
career is going to end in his 30s and
he's never met his father that's pretty
good
that's a great job I think I had one of
you like Mateo uh you know he what was
it is that I'm very he's from Brooklyn
but he spends all his time in Queens
I like I love Rose so I I we but I'm bad
I'm easy to roast and I'm bad at roast
it was on TV so I was like I'll tell you
because you were nervous I remember
before and I was like I'll tell you all
my jokes about you I don't know
nothing's mean right I had a roast that
I wrote because they asked us to write
roasts for Pete homes and so my roast
that they said which I still think was
funny and I love Pete I'm friends with
it but I said um Pete why does your face
look like the third version of the Mrs
doubt fight fire mask I thought that was
kind of funny I had one that you use on
him I think I gave it to Jamie Lee who
was like uh you know Pizza born again
Christian Pete uh Jesus isn't coming
back and either is your wife they both
got nailed and are in a better place
that was mine yeah man keep that in your
back pocket I'd just reuse it yeah for
anyone yeah that Twinkies are [ __ ]
good I haven't had one forever can I
have a Twinkie I'll try it I haven't had
a Twinkie in so long about an hour
what what are these we're drinking by
the way yeah so today we're drinking uh
kind of like the trendiest cocktail in
the last month
with a splash of Prosecco a Negroni
spagliato
famous that was going around no oh so
the girl in Game of Thrones the new Game
of Thrones how to drag him she meant to
say
negroniato which already has Prosecco in
it so it's for some reason it took off
online she was like all right my
favorite drink is Negroni with Prosecco
spogliato like she just said it wrong
and that was everywhere like it just
blew up the internet and like every bar
has them people because people are
asking them because of this actress yeah
this is good yeah there's a pumpkin I
don't think it is it is I don't like
Twinkies what these like went through
the Holocaust they can't they like last
uh 10 million years they don't go back
cockroaches and Twinkies they share
that's how you know it's not good
quality no I know it's just couch
cushion and I was trying to be on my
diet and here I am sitting in front of I
was eight like I ate everything
no I was I did a lot I was smoking
cigarettes drinking cigarettes only in
Italy I'm one of those I'm one of those
white women it's like it's disgusting
and then the second you get there I'm
like I have a cigarette
I was vaping like a [ __ ] the
other night because I'm out with my age
and gab and she just takes a vape out in
the bar and I'm just like I guess I'm
just I'm just you're drunks you're just
dragging it all night but is it a
nicotine is it oh okay but it was like
some never satisfying as cigarettes no
no no no no cigarettes will hit you yeah
I told you guys ever smoke I've had a
few
drinking smoke you know never yeah never
I was never like I need a cigarette
sober I'll do anything when I'm drunk
and we're neighbors no that's right
that's right don't pick up if I call
don't pick up get married
oh my God you got married oh yeah
unless you got cold feet yeah well we
might die down in New Orleans you think
so well we're gonna go hard I'm assuming
I'm getting there a night early good and
I think you're flying out the next
morning oh it's gonna be rough that's
gonna be real rough yeah but that's
gonna suck I'm gonna try to get a later
flight but I'm going I'm going straight
to South Carolina I don't have a lot of
options oh that's true but it's not too
far I know but the options suck yeah you
don't want to drive the six hours either
I don't want to drive ever no no you're
so New York I love you you're such a New
Yorker I can't because it's someone from
Chicago it's kind of fascinating and
exotic in a way to meet someone growing
up in Manhattan are you a public yes but
nothing you were like 13 getting on like
the four five six that's crazy to me
younger than that I think oh yeah yeah
that is why this is disgusting too
pumpkin so we gotta try pumpkin soda no
crackle you need an opener
thank you
same size
that's [ __ ] rough with the fixings
hold on
get y'all y'all get your fixings where
did you find this [ __ ] Clan rally
why pumpkin is overrated it's I'm gonna
get sick you guys what is this pumpkin
so pumpkin pie
spices it comes out once a year that's
right
that is disgusting that's not good you
see these there's that place in uh
Cleveland right by hilarities it sells
like 500 of those different flavored
things they have like vomit flavored uh
it's like the Harry Potter beans
remember like the beans that had all
those flavors
I know no idea I wasn't a big Harry
Potter fan but I mean I I just tried
watching Lord of the Rings the new Lord
of the Rings because I'm watching house
the dragon and Lord of the Rings and
Lord of the Rings was really terribly
written I never watched it they spent a
billion dollars on this show and it was
a flop really yeah it was I now like
this is the new Lord of the Rings it was
like Amazon did a TV series and they it
just was terribly paced and ew really
Mark you like it give it a little kick
you know spagliato the house of power
was great or House of dragon oh is it
good I loved it I'm very much I never
watched Game of Thrones oh it's fun you
know what you're on the road a lot you
should start watching I might start but
you know the problem was I really
started getting pushed watched it the
last season and every week they were
like you gotta watch it and then after
every episode came out they're like it's
the biggest piece of [ __ ] I've ever seen
it got way worse yeah just the last
video no I heard it's great but if
you're like we're all I don't know if
anyone travels more than us three so
it's like if you're on a plane just to
watch it because it makes the flights
fly by you know what you know when I was
just watching again that like I'd never
finished so I started from the beginning
and I started watching again is uh
Atlanta it's really good I never watched
it it's great it's such a good show
right right Donald Glover's [ __ ] good
he's great he's great it's like rap it's
like black thing yeah yes what about
music and not you know comedy but it's
like that type where it's like one
episode could just be like anything yeah
I just started watching the office again
oh it sounds good I love the office I
got into it during the pandemic yeah and
you never watched it before no wildly
offensive when you watch it you're like
whoa that was a [ __ ] joke or that was
a gay joke that was a black joke like
they went for it early season and it was
NBC the episode where the Oscar was gay
and then Michael was like kissing him I
mean even it's so even as a gig I was
like oh this is so painful to watch it's
so Michael is sucked but he's like
because George Costanza I'm obsessed
with Seinfeld but George gives me ajita
I get so anxious watching George and but
for some reason Michael doesn't in the
office it doesn't give me the same yeah
I know that is well it's so over the top
you know well I think the problem with
George is you know that Larry David
really did a lot
whereas with my with Michael you're like
well this is an insane that's how they
get away with or at least got away with
that type of behavior where they're like
well this is clearly an imbecile right
right but that's comedy you should be
allowed to make characters like that I
do think it's harder to make even like
an anti-hero like you couldn't make
Eastbound and Down now you don't think
no way no one would make that [ __ ]
what's the same with All in the Family
you got a racist he's the center of the
whole show and people are like you can't
have that but like he was the punch line
it worked because like and then you have
the over-the-top liberal right that's
where uh B Arthur came by where it was
discovered with Mod oh that's right she
was the sister and she came in and then
they were like she's so good they gave
her mod yeah yeah same with Fraser here
Frazier was a spin-off of cheating oh
that's right off of Cheers
it does seem like they're all gay oh oh
yeah just like it's a very gay straight
show yeah I mean it was like Neil grace
before it's like Will and Grace with no
yeah but it was it was nice
moving Grace is also oh Leslie Jordan
just died
I met him once really he could not have
been any nicer we did a gay cruise
together which I'll never do a cruise
again I absolutely hate what's a gay
Cruiser isn't it just a cruise
[Laughter]
yeah it was pretty horrible bruising
cruising just because have you seen that
movie with uh it's been a while with
Pacino yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
this is more fun than family
Thanksgiving It's Gonna Be by a lot oh
yeah and I love my family but this is
more fun yeah I know Thanksgiving wasn't
a big thing for my family well because
it was my dad's side of the fan my mom's
the Italian Mexican side so my dad's
side was just the you know Irish white
side and so we and I love his family but
they're not as many or interesting you
know so my all my cousins and I were
just like missing each other on
Thanksgiving because we're like we can't
be with each other and then obviously
Christmas is all Italians that was fun
but Thanksgiving was always like just
kind of American food
I'm gonna catch a lot of flack for this
I think we should just do Chinese food
on Thanksgiving
I love it what the hell you crazy we got
the turkey we got the stuffing we got
the green I don't like turkey and I do
not like stuffing so I don't like gravy
I said it there's a pretty shortage
there's all these turkey problems or at
least turkey's dry and bad
[Laughter]
at least we'll start it slow we get a
side of General so is in there maybe
some Mushu a couple egg rolls you're
like China you're you're inkling in
slowly your troops are at the gates but
very like I love Chinese food especially
and I'm the I'm the cause I get mad
people and they don't know what real
Italian food is I know I'm the dumb
American that has no idea about anything
about Chinese Cuisines there's a style
of New York Chinese yeah very much
Sichuan around in this neighborhood dude
it's pretty good pretty damn good you
know I I and you have to get like
something like General Style's chicken
you have to get in the restaurant
otherwise it comes too soft you know
when you order it online oh yeah it
comes like mushrooms for your last
relationship
also same yeah yeah I know what you mean
but I don't I'm not a big fan of I know
it's controversial I'm not a big fan of
turkey or gravy mashed potatoes I like I
like deli turkey I don't like like I'm
hanging out with Isis here come on I
like turkey we're gonna have stuff with
green bean casserole no not that goddamn
green bean I do like the marshmallow
yams on the time marshmallow yeah you
put these on yeah
Jesus Christ
I like when someone makes macaroni and
cheese mashed potatoes okay I like
cheese is overrated too unless it's got
the good job if you've never had good
macaroni cheese the bread crumb crunch I
don't know I'll give it to you
that's white people
Kanye that is white people macaroni and
cheese real macaroni and cheese does not
have bread crumbs on top I no one wants
breadcrumbs on top I want a crunch
because the cheese is supposed to be so
good like like
that's your crush okay then that's
acceptable I think I've had a lot of
mediocre mac and cheese I will take you
to a place that's got great mac and
cheese take me yeah this restaurants
that just do mac and cheese smack that's
the one Mac is all right
something really I mean also
controversial I do still love craft a
box of crafts either my friend from
college yeah my friend from Italy
Alessandra was like I don't understand
why your cheese is orange and powder but
it's very good yeah I'm like I know it's
not bad you're freezing it you know yeah
I like it but I I'm if I have a Cheesy
craving in New York it's like pizza
every time sure of course of course now
what kind of pizza do you guys like best
because I'm born in Chicago of a super
Italian family not living in New York I
love Chicago Pizza I prefer things I got
Chicago pizza with you for the first
time
yes but it's a fun it's a day under that
type of pizza oh you have two slices you
want to put a rope around your neck yeah
but you're so heavy after that [ __ ] it
would break the Rope it's you know what
I mean it's terrible I break the Rope no
it's uh I like uh thin crust cold oven
we just went to Arturo's last week Liz
Rachel Keith Robinson and we uh Keith we
had fun we got Arturo's we got a I love
Joe's Joe's is good Joe's for like a
late night slice I love uh [ __ ] John's
we've done John's before
John's on uh I've not gone there yet
pies only no slices really that's the
thing I could get down with that I had I
had a slice on it's in the Lower East
Side I want to say it was like another
famous place Krista Stefano's picture
was on the wall really yeah yeah that's
all day goes all guineas and I was like
oh there's of course Chris and stuff
like I [ __ ] love this pizza it's so
[ __ ] good it's my favorite my
daughter loves it uh [ __ ] TT loves it
everyone loves it yeah [ __ ] great I
know Lombardi's Lombardi's is good but
it's a little overrated best pizza in
New York which is a Naples Pizza is
rebalta on 12th Street I don't know that
one and it's probably Andrew there too
yeah only David was like he loved it
he's such a good pasta though too really
good pasta yeah we did it up we got to
go back then what's it called I want a
good Balta rebalta all right kitty
corner to the Strand oh all right great
but everyone's from Italy even the
clients like it's all Italians okay
because Joe's is all Mexican now have
you been to Joe's yeah of course it's
all Michael J joke I want remember
Michael J that bit where he's like I
want some authentic pizza brought to me
by Mexicans yeah yeah that was great
being both Italian and Mexican it's you
know what's funny is is like at
restaurants whereas Italians and
Mexicans working with each other or
Italians at least Latinos is the mix of
Italian and Spanish it's like its own
language right because they're so
similar and you can hear this like it's
like there's just about to do some kind
of documentary it's literally this
made-up language in these restaurants
that the Italians and Latinos oh really
they combined them they combine the
languages which is great this is rebalta
okay this is like they have two types of
pizza but like the individual style like
the ones above or like a dock is what I
get on the right uh okay that looks good
broccoli Rob on a pizza with sausage
that sounds pretty nice too they also
have a great uh meatballs really soft
not like you know you have some what did
uh Martin scorsese's mother say you take
thing you throw it against the wall the
wall cracks yeah
um really good dessert they have
something called um dude I didn't
realize he's had like five wives by the
way is that like I think maybe at least
three maybe really also Dennis Hopper
had like five all these guys from
Hollywood you're like grasses kind of
shocks me I just went down to Scorsese
Rabbit Hole the other day on YouTube
yeah
Family Guy really oh my God in the
[ __ ] 70s and 80s he was like
uncontrollable you know what good for
him hell yeah he married Isabella
rossolini
gorgeous one two three four hello
Douglas oh yeah she's in a few of the
movies
I think he dated or at least slept with
Liza Minnelli I'm not kidding yeah he
was banging her on a movie
or king of comedy uh wait so the Mars
Capone that uh Sandra Bernhardt I think
they're both in it oh maybe you're right
you're right that is um it's a whipped
marscapone like sweet it's I can't
describe it but it's it's [ __ ] it's
great it's really really good all right
love of all time is that your favorite
dessert Mars Capone yes that in New York
City this is my favorite dessert hmm
all right well James Corden will hate it
what did he do he
went Balthazar which by the way I'm a
native New Yorker I've never been a
Balthazar I went once I went once it's
not great it's a thing it's a scene
walking by with a friend the other day
and he's like we have to go and I was
like all right all right and then I was
like but I hate being like making forced
plans yeah I also hate waiting in lines
and there's always like huge lines
around unless you like know somebody or
I don't know the Real Housewives Are
there I was there once I saw Jared Leto
he's so hot he looks [ __ ] great he's
like 50 or something he's 29. would you
Jared Leto yeah are you [ __ ] kidding
me if he was like eat my [ __ ] I'd be
like yeah you need his poop that's no I
wouldn't go that far but you know I'd at
least consider it I mean he's hot that's
how you know you're hot yeah would you
eat my poop and you're like give me five
yeah yeah let me call my friends let me
let me consult all right Jared Leto
he looks doesn't he look fabulous I mean
he looks a little he's looking a little
like right there he's getting a little
Kristen Stewart yeah holy [ __ ] it's
transforming absolutely I feel like he
doesn't have a gender at this point
right like he hasn't picked it on
damned he's a guy he's ripped all right
he's back did you guys hear about how he
found out about the pen like the
quarantine of pandemic because he was
like doing a retreat in the desert in
Nevada Arizona somewhere for like three
months and then he came out in the
middle of it having heard nothing about
it because there's like no cell phones
oh wow it's just like a little Cult of
[ __ ] that he's doing so he came out and
he goes you know what I'm not doing this
I'm going back in just like retreated
back into the desert that sounds like oh
a nightmare yeah I know a desert like
everyone who goes to [ __ ] burning man
I'm just like no who are you who are you
no no Mary oh my God I was just talking
a girl was messaging me she's like I
gotta tell you all oh let's get a drink
and I'll tell you all about Bernie man I
was like I'll get a drink with you if
you promise not to talk I know because
Sam that's the most interesting thing
that she's done in her life yeah she
wants to tell you about she sitting in
sand and having sand in her [ __ ]
armpit and nose and vagina if you went
to fire Festival I'll listen oh all
right if it's burning man I don't give a
[ __ ] I'd say I had chlamydia twice one
year they called me birdie all right
chlamydia three times in one summer oh
he beat me the summer of Chrissy yeah
gonorrhea is worse than chlamydia
oh you get some uh what do you call it
uh discharge oily with the Ghana yeah
it's rough yeah thanks again for that
yeah
you said you needed sugar and one thing
led to another so Jared Leto who's like
who else is like a yeah a hot celeb oh
that's a good question hot salad you
know who I used to love back in the day
was Eric Bana oh yeah he's a hot guy I
thought he was [ __ ] dude Munich so
he's [ __ ] up he's yeah he's like a
badass Jew so extra points oh is he oh
have you not seen Munich I have said
that's a great it's a great movie no no
he's always I'm thinking of him in
Destroy oh he's playing type in Eric
Bana and Troy this is when he was like I
was like model I remember being like
he's so high he go he kind of went away
I think he's probably making like better
films but like ah yeah let's see what
he's been up to oh yeah he's a hunk yeah
I mean he's like a manly or Hugh Jackman
why were why were we just looking at
Brad Pitt in this movie oh just because
he can sing he's [ __ ] Wolverine dude
ah good point it's enough of what I'm
done with Wolverine it's enough really
it's enough already I I haven't seen
Logan I hear it's great it's fun I don't
care about that [ __ ] care I mean what
do you want him to be doing more music I
want I want like let's get storms right
boys they've got like seven storm don't
Mark get out you are this is the gay
Marvel Corner
Raiders love storm why is that Katrina
because she was like a drag queen kind
and she was so over the top like every
time they would use her powers they'd be
like storm can you open the windows
she's like wins rise of the Thorns like
she was a sorceress she was dramatic she
had the hair the wet I mean amazed I'm
so wet all right that was a rain joke
but Halle Berry [ __ ] up that character
why she was because she was just like it
should have been Angela Bassett I feel
like that that's what everyone says yeah
yeah really now she's in wakanda and
black panther so we can't now it's you
can't mix it moves
you know what's his name brolinist
Thanos and uh Deadpool right excuse you
wait you're looking at Ryan Reynolds is
dead no he's uh Cable in Deadpool oh he
is yeah he's like the main villain in
Deadpool 2. come on no damn well you
know what maybe because you can hear the
vaginas drying out there all this nerd
talk when all the dicks are going up
yeah I guess so all right
demographic would you guys have more men
or women for sure yeah men for sure like
two are probably gay
yeah they're hosting the show
yeah my demographic is mostly men
although on YouTube it's more women
really interesting I think it's like
cook or something I don't know ah yes
yes yes my lady will suck up any cooking
stuff really love to cook British Bake
Off all that stuff yeah obsessed but
yeah the plight of a comedian you got a
[ __ ] bitching's part of the job I love
complaining and I hate when you hang out
with normal people and they're like you
complain a lot I'm like God I miss
comedians that's New York energy too
it's not just Comics it's it's New
Yorkers it's how New Yorkers relate to
people you complain for 30 minutes and
then you go Life's good yeah yeah that's
how we that's how we talk to each other
we get it out and it's more fun to
complain than going life is great how
great is everything I hate but there's
no sense in being false with with one
another you know what I mean like like
we're all like everything's wonderful
and great and Grand it's like yeah well
I've collected a good Cruise make the
bitching somewhat funny I mean yeah yeah
because she goes all you do is come
plane and now you have a piece section
on your podcast you're monetizing your
whining hell yeah that's called I love
your mother I mean what do you think
Seinfeld and all that like Pat nozzle
has that great joke about uh he's like
yeah it sucks I love my wife you know
which is not really funny hey hey cuddle
time love you hugs and kisses you know
it's not it's not funny yeah playing is
funny and my my crew of like my crew of
gays are are very very funny [ __ ] mean
to each other type of people
yeah those two gates are pretty mean no
in a fun way in a fun way New York gays
at least our culturally sassy I think
yes yeah I mean I think just like you
know we sort of Run This Town yeah you
know what I mean yeah yeah you got
Broadway got Broadway we've got all the
west side yeah and uh it's also funny
like dead of winter there's just they're
still walking around with an iced coffee
I'm never an iced coffee me neither I'm
always happy because Summer I'm still
hot same yeah yeah well the gays are
interesting because they get labeled as
like wussy you know twink boys but
they've Irish what is that uh tells
kitchen used to be like Irish gangs and
now it's all gay hmm they won
the village Chelsea yeah you got the
whole west side yeah it's impressive The
Gangs stepped back for a second like
they're making this area pretty nice
yeah yeah yeah exactly [ __ ] the gangs
gang bang Let's Go All In
[Laughter]
[Music]
I can't even look at him it's so hot
like that kind of face you're like I
wouldn't even know what to do if you
were in the room with me I would
literally jump out a window yeah it's
like too good looking
um I don't know that's cool when you get
a gig where you just have to be in shape
so he's just got trainers all day yeah
making sure he's ripped for like another
Creed yeah what am I training for yeah
yeah I haven't done those kind of photos
in a long time now I just do comedy go
back to the pics come on I don't feel
anything for Helmsworth really why not I
think they're beautiful but I just know
Harry Styles no I'm not into Harry
Styles I think I like what he represents
and I like his music but like as a
sexual like do I want to have sex with
Harry Styles I don't because he's a
homewrecker yeah or I'll with the rock
I'm not he's hot I understand he's basic
is he basic yeah he's just boring I get
enough he doesn't seem interesting okay
Brad Pitt of course I mean beautiful
absolutely beautiful
yeah I could yes I could okay yeah all
right I think he just Elvis oh my God
look at Michael B Jordan I mean he is
like the hot that that's [ __ ] he's
got like an eight pack what is his arm
doing on the right I know it's bursting
through that sleeve it I mean it doesn't
look a little Photoshop
you would know yeah dude we all look the
same shirtless come on [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh
how did he make it all right
he's like 50 something Jewish is he yeah
hey score one for the try he's money
we're all right he's my number one it's
really Henry if I was gonna go for a guy
that would be my guy top or bottom oh
he's got to be a top all right I would
take that I would check your sources
no you are sassy I have no that was
sassy as [ __ ]
um speaking of Game of Thrones I just
hated Aquaman so much I have no respect
for him oh wow I was watching at stov's
Place one day and we're just watching I
was like damn Amber Heard is really hot
not that way she was I like that red
hair
awful that wig was worse than that
divorce trial Zac Efron who [ __ ] up
his jaw he almost died and I think had
to get reconstruction surgery I probably
got some like other fillers to even out
whatever happened and people just read
them for Filth they were like he [ __ ]
up his face look at his [ __ ] up
plastic surgery [ __ ] his jaw he ran into
a wall or something and like his dog
dislocated and then he like made some
comment about it he was like yeah I
almost died but thanks for making me
feel like [ __ ] I was like okay working
interesting Jason Statham yay or nay nay
nay he's pretty cool though fine yeah
that's all it took
I don't know worse George Clooney it was
so this photo is awful yeah I mean he
looks this is an awful awful photo
really well it looks like one of those
like I don't know and Leibowitz like a
child gave birth we're putting it in a
flower type photo like what is this
that's a weird one it's a weird photo
I'm uncomfortable Robert Downey Jr I do
not think he's attractive I like the
smoking okay like a bad boy
Jared Leto we've discussed it I said yes
number one up there probably Michael B
Jordan is fine I mean that is yeah I
also Bradley Cooper's hot but also I'm
just not like I know sometimes we're
told people are the hottestines
are they I agree there's a lot of ladies
like that too okay well they tell you
like Julia Roberts is so hot I'm like
she's uh she's pretty she's like a
pretty lady but I'm not very beautiful
I'm not like there's no sex appeal with
her to me really yeah I just think she's
like a pretty lady I wouldn't say she's
uh you don't want to throw her down and
you know give her the business I met
Johnny Depp I was uh for some reason I
was at Jimmy Kimmel my friend was
working there or something and I was
when you go in I went through the back
and he was outside smoking and this must
have been a rough time in his life
because he was a little heavier than
usual but when I walked by him he was
smoking and I thought to myself that
person would be a perfect Johnny Depp
imitating oh but they're you know they
might be a little too like uncapped a
little dope because I was so used to
walk up to him you would be a great
Johnny Depp if you weren't so fat can
you imagine yeah and it's not even it
wasn't it's not I'm not using the word
fat it's just I was used to one giant
depth and he looked very uncomfortable
and I think it was during his drinking
yeah wow so which is not the only one
throwing [ __ ]
all right it was wild when she shot
through it anyway so I it was funny that
I walked by him he did he's he's very
attractive like young Johnny Depp is
very insane gorgeous oh my God gorgeous
Edward yeah he gave me Edward
thank you good actor really seems to
good right it's kind of a fun is that it
that's the end of the list
ah chocho
he's good I don't think I know what John
Cho is he's in a ton of stuff oh
Columbus Cowboy Bebop live action oh I
think that guy he was good enough I
think he's a handsome guy he's handsome
Ryan Gosling cute cute
and [ __ ] great in the nice guys come
on Leonardo DiCaprio is a little I don't
quite get it well he's aging out a
little bit he as a kid he was well
that's gorgeous wouldn't it be funny if
he just went the way of Brando and just
got super fat but was still [ __ ]
everyone he might he might go there he
could go there he could be like
Apocalypse Now Brando and we'd be like
yeah whatever so when you're when you're
a 22 year old Victoria's Secret model
and you go on a date with Johnny Depp
you know the expiration date like he
only dates 20 year olds he's doing with
Leo yeah Leonardo that's all he dates
yeah right because then it's like then
he breaks up with him once they reach
like 26 or 27 it's like done yeah so in
my mind I'm like does do you think like
these the girls are thinking well I'll
just go along for the ride this is kind
of a credit or like I'm gonna change him
and marry him probably a little of both
so I think there's a lot of uh I get to
bang Leo you know that's on my resume
now and I've been like it's like a comic
you know what a bad crowd you're like
I'll get him
there's a lady probably like I'll get
him there you see the comics a comic you
respect bombing before you're like they
don't know how to reach him okay I'll
turn it around exactly how do you handle
like when like a really bad Heckler like
not even in a fun way just keeps like
kind of [ __ ] up the vibe I I hate I
hate it I go nuts and I've been getting
that more and more
like I'm getting now you do you guys get
I'm getting the Super Fan who's so
excited that he's ruining the show yes I
just had that and I kicked him out last
week and a couple weeks ago in Dallas
drives me insane bro they're like I love
you you're great I'm a fan like all
right you're ruining me that's where you
get in Texas honestly because you get a
combo of like the best people and just
animals like you get because like Dallas
Houston's another one Houston dude well
they party in Houston
so you get that like you get that like
fun guy energy so part of the crowd like
the best crowd you've ever had yeah I
had one dude the whole show was like
please just take a picture with me I'm
like now I know and I was like [ __ ] it
just to shut them up I like take my mic
I would go down I take a selfie with him
uh-huh and then he just keeps going yeah
you're rewarded bad behavior I did I
didn't know what else to do I go to
Great Lengths to not get someone kicked
out yes I I don't want them to get
kicked I do really because I what what
bothers me is I'm on stage my biggest
thing I don't mind if someone's like you
know like the worst thing to me is if
I'm in the middle of a bit and someone's
talking at me it [ __ ] up my it's like
music it [ __ ] up my rhythm same and
then I can't get into the Rhythm and
then I'm stuttering and now I've lost
the Rhythm and the connection with the
crowd yeah and it's like because this
guy won't shut up and I'll say like if
you don't stop talking like I know
you're I'll give him a war I'm like hey
I'm like I know you're excited to be
here but just like I'm letting you know
like you're talking it kind of messes me
up a lot and if they keep doing it I'm
like you gotta go I get warnings too but
I really really don't want I feel for
drunks I really do I've been there I do
not well Mark and I drink more than you
so I think there's a part of us that's
like we've been that young drunk kid so
I think then then this is where they
learn their lesson how to hold their
liquor maybe otherwise you're rewarding
bad behavior and the next comedy show
they go to they drink even more because
I just got the worst message ever I'm
sure you guys hate this message I'm
coming to your show in DC next week a
bunch of friends I thought you're gonna
say I'm pregnant and it's yours but okay
a bunch of friends we're gonna get
wasted and come to the show I get that
all the time and I wrote back I said
okay I said just letting you know they
will kick you out if you if you disrupt
the show yeah that's so I wrote back
people there's this weird misconception
that the comedy show is a party you know
like the Burke christers of the world
we're all gonna woo take our shirts off
and you know fist pump and do shots and
that's the after party that's the after
party yeah but but I have a set I got a
performance I got to do I think people
see the videos most I'll say most of my
crowds very well behaved that comes out
I mean you have some wild people in your
but I do but I also you have to realize
I record every set and I do a shitload
of sets so people think that but I just
do so many shows yeah so what is that
one out of like 10 shows there's a
weirdo sure it's nothing maybe even
nothing and you get the clip and you get
a funny clip to promote [ __ ] where I
don't have to burn material but uh no I
think they're actually Minecraft's
really well behaved I mean we have a
similar yeah by the way
oh dude I just did your show and they
were awesome that was so fun uh but yeah
I will get that occasional message
people are like it's my friend's
birthday can you roast him I'm like no I
don't know anything about roast him I
know that's like for your close friends
it is it's a real narcissist I always
say to people when they interrupt shows
like there's 600 people and one person I
what I my go-to line because we all
go-to's I'm like I I will Point them I
want everyone to see this is what a real
narcissist looks like
it's so loaded coming from a person
holding a microphone that isn't that
shocking it's how ironic but it's true I
said so many people flew here or got
babysit well not baby no one has kids in
my shows but I'm like you know I'm like
the people came from long distances and
you came here and thought tonight's
about me no one else has behaved this
way but for some reason it's okay by me
so everyone this is a real narcissist
that's good that's good it's a good
title for a special though real
narcissist at least we get it out in a
healthy way
and then you can kind of shut off and be
a person I think that's that's not bad
because they do like seeing like like
like what's going on behind the curtain
oh they love to stop like the
performance aspect and you get really
real you know because for the for the
most part they really do think like
we're just talking off the top of our
heads right so when you're really
getting real they're like some of it's
off the top of our heads right I mean we
always I mean no one show is the exact
same as another show no no no no not at
all ideally it would be but yeah but
also but you know what I kind of like
being thrown just a little bit it keeps
you from going on autopilot yeah yeah
just a hint even you want it to be
different I feel like it's bad for your
brain to do the same that's true I'm
forcing myself now I said I know I have
my hour and I'm working to I'm just
doing the first 25 minutes or just new
material well good for you guys I just
can't and it's the best to do on the
road because everyone's excited exactly
but I'm like I'm so sick of my jokes I
heard a comic once say uh if you have a
joke where you say so five years ago but
just the next time say four years ago
and the time of that say six because it
makes you not go on autopilot because
you have to remember to change it I
heard stories that David tell you I'm
sure he still does this but uh he would
just he would have attacked it killed
and he would just do a different tag
every show yeah and people be like you
that you have it works why and he's like
well I just want to try I mean it makes
sense it keeps you present it keeps you
looking for more it keeps your brain a
lot that's strange that you're in front
of like a thousand people and you're
like you're you're fighting with
yourself you're like get into it like
you know like if you go on autopilot
you're fighting the autopilot I know you
know what I mean not that it happens
often but the times that it does and
you're like
isn't that strange but we're not we're
not Broadway actors I mean this isn't a
scripted show I mean look there's a
script that we break it's almost like
more closer to like a curb episode than
it is where you like you have you know
where it's gonna go and you have lines
but I think you do have to keep trying
different things or you'll get bored
yeah that's for sure I was trying to run
my hour in Dallas and it was like I had
six shows and I was like by the fourth
show Caitlyn palufo who's a [ __ ]
amazing comedian we got to get her on
here we got to get her she drinks too oh
she's the she's so amazing killer yeah
killer and uh and fun to hang with great
super fun
um yeah we did a gig together a while
back and we had a ton of fun oh she's
the best she's the best like an old
sailor she'll throw him back yeah she's
parties she um uh but with the black
kids oh yeah and it's but it's good
though I like that too I'm like she's
murdering right now so good I gotta step
up my [ __ ] yeah I gotta get up there
and really try but the last two shows
was like [ __ ] it I I just took up my
notebook of the [ __ ] that I'm working on
at the cellar put it on stage and just
did as much as I possibly could and it
was like you get off stage and like I
feel like I have a soul again yeah like
it just fills you up so much I know what
I do is I do a full 45.50 and I do a q a
and I can tell they're like oh we can we
can relax a little because you know I
was gonna ask you about that do you just
say like ask me any questions thank you
that was a set they applaud and I go you
guys have any questions and I should say
shout out a news story or something yeah
I do the same thing I've been doing it
for a while because I'm just like I get
bored and it's a way to to scare myself
like yeah yeah can I do this exactly and
I remember opening for Dave when I would
open for a towel he would bring me up on
stage or whoever was opening because he
would get bored right I think it was a
way to like challenge himself and be
like I can you know make this work and I
with news stories it's a way to be like
all right I read the news yeah I have an
angle on everything I don't have a bit
but I always have a I have an inkling
yeah where I could go and that's enough
to guide you and to scare you in a like
you know trust that muscle memory like
I'm a comic let's [ __ ] think of a
joke on the fly yeah you're on your toes
again and I love that and the crowd is
so invested they're on the edge of their
seat like oh what's he gonna say or what
am I gonna yell out yeah I think that
too they're like I wish I could think I
should they're asking their friends like
should I ask this should I ask that yeah
you know what it's like it's like it's
like you're a power hitter and the
pitcher's throwing the ball all over the
place and there's like a ball over here
and a ball over here but every once you
get one right down the [ __ ] pipe
right you just destroy it and you get
that extra love yeah because they're
like holy [ __ ] spontaneous I just had a
crowd work special but I called the
advice specialist I did Justice it
should be November 20th so maybe by now
out but who knows on YouTube about
YouTube Mateo Lane yeah Mateo Lane
um and it was shot beautifully we did it
at the village underground we did two
shows back to back but the first show
was like the week was I on that one you
were the second show which I'm gonna do
something with also we had fun I had a
blast with you you didn't know I knew
that much about musicals did you well
then we've been like oh you're in New
York and Jewish like of course you do
like you know what I mean why
um but it was it was like kind of like
that where I said just ask me give me a
ask me a question I'll give you advice
yeah so instead of me being like you you
they started shouting you know of course
it's all gays right so it's not just
gonna be like you know I think my
boyfriend's cheating on me this one guy
was like so I'm sleeping with this guy
and um he uh lives on the floor above me
but he doesn't speak any English and he
told me that he has to stop seeing me
because he needs to get closer to his
wife I'm like this is great like I spent
15 minutes yeah we did q a at the end of
your show that was so fun it is fun to
do that because it's like it's testing
it is testing our skills in a way yeah
like am I actually funny or can I just
write some stuff and it's fun but I
think you get into this because you're
naturally funny and then you or you know
but there's two types of comedians
there's Comics who are like in their
head right kind of writer types and
there's people who are just like on all
the time right right you know and then
there's some people who have a little
bit of both classmen
shout out Rick Glassman I think my I
always like because I can't I know like
do you go to coffee shops and right I
used to all the time I don't have a
[ __ ] free minute anymore yeah it's
crazy you need to rest really yes
because you and I are going through the
same thing and he texts me that he's
like I'm exhausted I said same don't put
in at the cellar come home and do
nothing for two days right two days to
do nothing two days oh that's crazy
yeah come on when you go to the gym and
have sex or something oh okay but um
yeah I should do that but let's do both
those things
the way I grew up with all my cousins
and stuff everyone is very witty it's
very one-uppy like everyone one UPS each
other here Mark take mine because I'm
not gonna drink and um uh so I realized
like your family's very cool they're
okay but yeah they love they're obsessed
with we met in Chicago and they're so
they're so nice and and warm and they're
very funny and um I think now I'm like
oh when I'm on stage I write the best
because it's like the same sort of
bouncing off energy yeah so that I need
an audience in order to write
interesting yeah I've gotten so many not
so many I've probably got like five bits
out of the riffing it's good it's good
for you did I make this too serious
about comedy no I love it hey man we go
up and down all right I think this pod
is trying to talk about stand up a lot
it's great you're the best stand-ups
dude I love I love watching you because
you're always doing new [ __ ] so I'm
pumped to see the special this is the
the my special that I'm hopefully gonna
make in January who God knows what's
gonna happen with it but um my hours I'm
very excited about my hour but the crowd
work special it was like I was really I
had a [ __ ] blast yes it was amazing
amazing I can't wait the those are fun
and those do better people like those
better I think yeah I think so too it's
like freestyle rap versus like versus
like an album they're like holy [ __ ]
they came up off the top of their Dome
there it's like it's kind of cool oh
yeah it's like a bar fight versus you
know a boxing game what is it MMA MMA
MMA yes what do you have any peeves
lately is there anything bugging you a
lot lately
um I'm traveling a lot and I I hate sick
people on planes I was just flying back
from Italy because it's like it makes me
this one next to me on the plane was
coughing like she should be in the ICU
really that's the worst literally and
she had she did have a mask but I kept
putting that air thing to like like to
defend myself just the noise is is
there's also too it's like you knew you
she was like sick yeah [ __ ] you knew
you were this sick and you got on an
eight and a half hour flight this is how
Ebola started I know and then you can
hear the gurgle there's that flemmy well
that's what you know they're really sick
when it's like wet yeah ah that'd be a
great just be a short sketch just like
you're just sitting there kind of
reading your paper and the person just
like oh
after I do the
because I wanted to know she made a
mistake she shouldn't have done that I
was so mad no I do get it I do get
annoyed uh
monster I was really coming back but I
was like I don't want to make that noise
I was like fighting tonight did you wear
a mask I had a mask yeah I didn't have
covert but I was just I just don't want
to get people [ __ ] I was uh I just had a
really bad upper respiratory infection I
was sick as [ __ ] and I'm just like just
wear the mask just to not yeah people
sick but I had an allergic reaction I
ate an octopus in Spain once years ago
and it can get code
honestly that's the straightest thing I
could have ever said that I had octopus
in Spain this is like when a Hemingway's
early works yeah right it was 1874 and I
had octopi in Spain and the Liberian
um and it caused a rash all over my body
and I had like a really bad reaction and
the girl next to me like kept like going
like that like I was gonna give her
leprosy or something like [ __ ] it's
just an allergic reaction I looked like
a freak I mean I look like people were
like oh like like yeah flight attendants
were scared of me yeah well the coughing
is in the words of a Theo Vaughn since
kovid coughing is the new n-word you
know like when someone coughs you're
like whoa what the [ __ ] but if a black
person does it I'm like it's okay yeah
you made it cool
no it's uh it is definitely the coughing
does make me uncomfortable but I'm like
I also realize I'm like part of that's
the media I'm programmed to feel that
way now because of how much I've watched
with sickness but but
it is to do what we do sick like Thank
God I'm a low energy comic I'm in
Phoenix sick as a [ __ ] right
it's like can you go on and I was like
if I were Sebastian the answer would be
no but because I'm like this is my
energy yeah and I talk like this on
stage I'm I'm gonna tough it out but I'm
Lavelle Crawford it you got the wreck
Whitney Houston yeah
the top of her wig is stopping what yeah
I I wish my hotel at a tub oh my God
I'm a big Mariah person I've had a
tempestuous relationship with her why is
that well I used to make a bunch of
jokes about Mariah and um I don't make
them anymore I publicly apologize I I
was an Angry Young homosexual and uh you
know the more you're in this business
the more you get it yeah I see you're so
not I mean we all go through like phases
of anger but you're such a chill guy
you're so you don't you don't strike me
as an angry person no no I don't get
angry unless I'm unless I'm arguing with
someone about like pasta or something
like some stupid arbitrary but yeah with
Mariah
like a bunch of spices in it um yeah all
right are you seeing someone now or no
no I had a thing with this guy who I
really liked and we're supposed to be
friends but like it was almost five
months of talking every single day and
then we had a great vacation with each
other and I I said I brought up I was
like Hey like should we do long distance
and he and rightfully so in his own
right he was like I just can't because I
can't do long distance and I was kind of
gut punched because I was like oh but
like well then what we were working
towards you know what I mean and
honestly whoever dates any of us has to
do with long distance you got that right
because we're not home now anyone who
wants to be with me is a red flag I
agree yeah same way what the hell but I
know what you mean that's why the road
is great because like my lady gets it
obviously but but it's a built-in
relationship saver like I go on the road
for three days it's the perfect amount
of time where you start to miss them
again you come back you're excited and
when you get annoyed you leave again
yeah it's perfect for a relationship I
don't know I really like this guy I
liked him a lot but I just just are you
still talking to him like less I mean I
I basically was like where's he what's
where's he living
he lives far enough America yeah he
lives it's shocking for me usually my
boyfriends are looking for a green card
um my girlfriend lives in Canada
how's he packing how's the noodle is it
rigatoni or angel hair it was
it was a nice manicotti
he was he's great he was a great guy but
I get it he couldn't do it so it's hard
to date I feel it's hard I feel slightly
more isolated
we're so busy that just giving up a
night I'm like I'm like this this girl
better be cool as [ __ ] if I'm not doing
seller spots I get this more and more as
women will like uh they'll be like I
can't do before nine I mean after not
after nine right so I'm like well I want
to do at least one spot just in case
this date sucks exactly you know and
then they're like already he's choosing
his job I'm like you're damn right yeah
what the hell yeah it will be the never
ending the other unwinnable war of
trying to date a comedian to see if they
can overcome them dinner is a sign of
stability to women yeah and dinner in a
show a movie a play I mean it's all nice
why can't we do like a 9 30 dinner uh
yeah that's not too much to ask you know
what I mean like New York that's normal
and guess what a breakfast and lunch the
[ __ ] out of you you got that right but
like dinner it's tough for some I'll do
it some nights but like oh man I'm I'm
gone so much on the road that when I'm
here I really do want to go up at the
cellar yeah but but here's why I'm a
[ __ ] you would never go hey I'll meet
you at uh 11 30 a.m while I'm at work
well
well I'm at work at nine that's a great
I said the same I said the exact thing
to a woman recently who she's like she
goes I'm always working around your
schedule I say well the fact that you're
saying that just shows you'll never
accept my lifestyle but it's also about
they don't respect they don't actually
respect what we do if they if you would
never say to a doctor oh I'm always
working around your schedule obviously
doctor saves lives we're not saving
lives but I'm just saying it's a respect
towards a job you're saying to me you
think what I'm doing is not is just fun
sing it sister you don't think why can't
you take a night off because it's a
slippery slope you you get me to take
this thing up and I'll take any night
off and it's like it's like [ __ ] I was
fighting with for years where people
were like well why can't you do this
it's a routine I have to do it every
night or I won't once you break it for
anything more and more yeah I have been
taking off because I'm home for three
days and my body is health reasons for
recharging because the road is the truth
so that that's that's where but a day
doesn't recharge no you're right that's
what works the road is where we make our
money and where we find our new jokes
it's hard in the shorter sets in the
city but it is a routine thing oh yeah
I'm home all December so I'll be putting
in spots every night yeah I'll be
putting a spot but that's a healthy way
like I was trying to do the do the road
then come back and do spots and my body
physically cannot take it I just can't
take certain performances we go to the
gym how many of those days a week too
yeah uh listen
they're also being physically healthy
also helps me on stage like I have eight
healthy tell me about it dude I I exert
a lot some Comics give me a cookie okay
yeah I know those Oreo cookies are
pretty good but I do exert a lot of
energy on stage and I become I kind of
come off like collapsed in a way I get
that I get that yeah and then I drink on
the road so that doesn't help then how
do you how do you first of all how do
you maintain a great body and also drink
on the road and have enough energy to
like
it's not easy but uh I don't eat bread
and that really helped me okay
a lot of bread I don't eat bread I've
watched you eat bread have you this is
Sam what are you eating I don't know
this is like a pumpkin cup where'd you
get that thing pumpkin cupcake
is it because let me try it I just want
to bite the arm
this is solid God damn there's cream in
the middle too oh what's this it's I'm
just so sick of pumpkin white women it's
Whitey
um
oh yeah that's solid it's dry as hell
yeah
I did not that was not good you don't
like this no it was really good actually
these are solid
that was the worst one I had oh I like
this one a little cream cheese frosting
or something on there right but yeah see
I thought that was the fun part about oh
being gay is you could just you want a
relationship
I don't know why right now I'm so career
from better better than this oh yeah
um
I don't know what I tell you I do not
know what I want but I'm so career
focused because I'm on a nice little
momentum momentum
um so I don't know I'm kind of just like
you're throwing costume of the win the
career weirdly everyone's like comedy
such an unstable Pursuit but it's the
only thing that's ever been stable in my
life same you know I mean uh in that in
that regard too yes I know I mean it's
it's with me the only thing that matters
in comedy are your jokes and other
comedians I've decided yeah nothing else
matters right like our what I'm doing on
stage is this good yeah right so the
audience is included on that and then my
relationship with other Comics
everything else is like yeah who cares
and when the jokes are good and your
relationship is good and you're saying
the career gets better that's right so
but the heart here's what annoys me and
this is where I'm gonna get [ __ ] online
but like a lot of views a lot of these
ladies are like hey uh you know you
don't take off what the hell you can't
give me a knight and you're like well
look I'll hang out with you but
what uh are you gonna be fun like if you
hang out with her are you still chucking
and driving well that's a hard mentality
to go into it when you're when you're
like well you better bring it if I'm
taking a night off but I definitely
think that way but you're gonna bring it
yeah I always bring it yeah I think we
always do it like okay I'll do what
normal people do and then 45 minutes in
you're like how do they do it
so true
come to this party and you're just like
no you're like bars yes yes
um never a party I want a table with
Comics chatting with friends with our
co-workers and that makes life so easy
like I'm like literally excited to go to
work every day right I'm like I'm
checking the lineup who am I hanging out
with tonight
oh yeah
but like you just sit at the table
someone you love sits down you're like
oh this is so easy Keith sits down my
heart just swells yeah I mean I know
we're gonna his new materials [ __ ]
it's he's so good he's so good I married
him don't we were dating her in the
pandemic I was like him me Liz and Jose
we were we saw each other every single
day made dinners at the cellar like
here's a new bit about taking a Viagra
as his flight lands he's pissed drunk he
knows he has a second stroke coming so
he's about to get laid so he ignores
this is the second time he's ignored a
stroke wow you think he'd know better he
goes and [ __ ] this woman is tells this
whole story but the only part of his
body that's working is his dick he's
walking to this woman like it's the
Night of the Living Dead and he still
[ __ ] her and it's like dude you had a
second stroke that's amazing he did it
for a second and then he ends up
basically being like I don't want to
give away too much but the gist of it is
like don't you ever tell us that you
think you like sex as much as men yeah I
mean it's like you're like Jesus Keith
he said something we're at dinner
together and he said something so
offensive and I just looked up and said
Keith God has smited you so many times
and he's still going and he's there
that's the beauty of it he just keeps
saying [ __ ] up [ __ ] I remember
immediately after the me too thing he he
defended Cosby like kidding obviously
but he's defending Cosby on stage and
it's killing I'm like that's how you
know the joke is [ __ ] hilarious that
a guy goes up there going like oh come
on he's a real guy he always goes
against the grid during the height of
BLM he was like I look at black people
like fire exits there's one over there
that's a great joke well he likes to
sort of like see he he gets excitement
it's like a science experiment if I add
this chemical to that chemical what's
the reaction I'm gonna get right right
that's where his joke he's poking you
but it's never maliciously it is that's
the thing that's the beauty of it you
can tell with Keith some people you mean
you're like oh there's like you ever
talk to someone and like you can just
tell talking to him like there's a dark
side oh yeah like real thinly failed
like there's a with Keith he can say the
most horrible [ __ ] but you do see very
clearly like Keith has a great heart and
he's a good father very good and he's uh
a questionable partner but uh but he's a
great father and he's a hilarious guy
and he's supportive of comics like I do
remember auditioning the comic strip
many years ago doing that dumb late
night thing they got judges they got
comments judges it was awful they tried
doing America's Got Talent type girl
judges oh I was who was Paula Abdul uh I
don't think they had one I think
it was all brutal and then we I remember
going on and uh
a lot of comics were kind of dicks to me
but Keith was like nah that was good he
was like the only one the only guy and
he was the only guy in the [ __ ] panel
who I respected so yeah yeah it meant a
lot but I was like holy [ __ ] and uh
Harrison by the way is a great gig in
Vegas
I'm like that is
good for him good for Harris we used to
live in Vegas
some people like Vegas I don't I mean I
want I haven't asked Harris so many
things in Vegas but I asked him I hate
things I absolutely hate it I'll be
there at the Mirage late January
terrible place
two shows I like I like the part of
Vegas that's not real it's drip do you
know what I'm talking about like that
when you're like you're in normal Vegas
it's like oh it's cool like you're just
hanging out those good restaurants and
stuff but it's that strip life yeah that
is the word it's like Souls that you get
there and you're like yeah God like I
just oh it's awful I grew up in New
Orleans that's like real real big like
what's culture there's food there's
music there's architecture then Vegas is
just you should be a bigger bachelor
party destination than New Orleans
because you have casinos too are you
saying New Orleans should be big that's
what I'm saying oh yeah I'm sorry yeah
yeah New Orleans you have Harris right
yeah you can't [ __ ] in New Orleans
yeah you can [ __ ] in Vegas you can
act a fool and [ __ ] New Orleans is
not going to put up with that no you'll
get jumped or something people leaving
Vegas look like they just got the [ __ ]
kicked out they look like people going
into video Even if you won you look like
you got the [ __ ] kicked out of you yeah
yeah well the flight there and the
flight out is very different the flight
to the plane lands everybody collapse
I've been drinking Jack and cokes the
whole flight and then then the flight
out is like I'm getting a divorce this
is paramedics coffee yeah give me a
coffee but the saddest thing is to see
like a woman in like early hundreds with
the oxygen tank smoking a cigarette
yeah right and you're like God the
indignity oh it just makes me like
Social Security New Orleans there's
music there's food there's lights
and your body has gone against you yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah terrible oh yeah
it's bad news yeah but do we know it's
sadder than Vegas Reno thank you oh I
had to do two weeks there I remember two
weeks yeah where were you Silver Legacy
okay where they shot the last scene
it was the dead of winter yeah and it
was Lake Tahoe and it was
um uh some Casino like a casino gig I
mean just just like I felt like The
Shining like and like I just wanted to
get out and I was like oh I just want to
kill myself and the only thing I could
watch the only thing on TV was the Harry
Potter marathon and I was like I guess
I'll watch Harry Potter I don't like it
that much and yeah entertainment there's
entertainment that has like saved my
life on the road oh dude tell me about
it it's like been on TV video games
video games is good I remember when we
were on the road we were both in Dayton
Ohio at the same time yeah Mateo brings
his N64 we're playing Mario Kart this
[ __ ] is incredible at it I am so
excited you don't lose never and we did
it on the tour bus with Aziz
I usually pick um Tanuki Mario oh okay
and I never know what that is he's got
like the raccoon outfit on oh the
raccoon yeah yeah and uh when we were
open for Aziz together what Phil Hanley
I never saw Phil because Phil is always
very like chill put together it was
losing
his last words screaming was like I was
in the mix oh
yeah I could have been a contender
literally and him and will still Vince I
mean the two of them playing and yelling
at each other it was comedy gold dude
that's a web series Comics playing video
games and trash talks
we should do a patreon in here where we
play video games that's fun oh my God
wait we showed her in here [ __ ] all
these guys let's get an N64 let's get a
[ __ ] perfect dark or no gold Knight
double seven and get the original
controllers but you have to find the
right TV because I just bought it you're
annoyingly good at every video game
you're one of those we gotta brush up I
need it let's get mad let's see how he
[ __ ] holds up
Madden okay Madden 64 was good okay
because you could like it wasn't just
like football you could like fight each
other um 3D hockey
[Laughter]
all right finally it wasn't the beer
juice
golden eye though
proximity mine either what was odd jobs
thinking too short so you miss him yeah
damn don't I was kind of revolutionary
oh I'm so I could nerd out about this a
lot yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I love
your nerdy Tendencies man all I do is
play video games fortnite and you play
with like yamanikins we gotta get yamas
so in the tournament [ __ ] funny we
were playing for now your new shit's so
funny I watched John is the Best
comedian I'm just putting it out there I
love her dude she's literally the Best
comedian Dominica Saunders follower
she's so funny killer she says [ __ ] when
you're playing fortnite I mean now don't
get it wrong her and I fight like cat
and dogs we scream at each other but we
have I there were times in the pandemic
because we played every single day with
each other yeah a year and a half and I
mean when I say we were laughing with
tears playing fortnite is one of the
funniest [ __ ] things ever but that is
how I survived before I was putting [ __ ]
up online and all that other stuff I was
kind of tanking yeah and the only way I
could pay rent during the pandemic was
twitch what I would play video games and
do like six hour shows and it was kind
of great I wrote a ton of material wow
that's not relatable
um I wrote a ton of material and it was
like you're getting my new Tanuki Mario
chunk yeah right can you imagine I mean
that's really not relatable Tanuki Mario
I mean I think it's a new heart
when you click on them again but
um I'm so good at voices oh thank you
how much voiceover do you do
um not as much as you would think I did
a cartoon show once and I played like an
evil villain
um I was this close to making it in Luca
Pixar's Luca for the villain they flew
me to Pixar I met with the director he's
from Italy we spoke in Italian the whole
time I did the audition and it went to
the one other person and then who was
cut to a year later I'm having lunch
with my friend salverio in Rome who's a
comedian in Rome and he goes yeah I just
did the voice for you know I said I was
the other person like oh my God
[Laughter]
I don't know what happened to him but I
do like doing voices I do a lot of like
women voices and stuff like I mean
because Evan Williams is my best friend
he does all like the male Impressions
Evan Williams doing like what what are
the best I could just call him he knows
we want to show one of his Clips on Tick
Tock where he's doing like guy Richie or
any other [ __ ] he does he'll send me
these clips I send him all the time I
love Evan here I'm just gonna I'm gonna
call him and make him do Impressions oh
great can we will that come through Matt
yeah yeah I do this all the time I call
my friend Nick all the time but get him
on on uh
Evan Williams Oh my God
we got him here
oh this guy yeah we start we started
Matt and just
every guy Richie Movie Evan Williams now
I do the perfect Evan Williams Oh okay
I'll show you okay we gotta hear him
first
of cash
hey John how do you speak John
I'm being drunk that's Big John
can I use the bathroom
is the dumbest law I've worked with wow
he's so good as a guy who likes guy
Richie movies he's done other [ __ ] what
are like the best ones he's done he does
really good GTA ones uh why is there a
car burning outside he goes oh whoa I
grabbed his car and I crashed it and it
started burning and then I walked in
here ah I don't I never played GTA
really nah I never got into it really I
thought you have Tetris all right here's
Evan hold on oh here we go all right
Evan you're on with Sam Morrell and Mark
Norman we'd want you to do a bunch of
impressions
wow okay so what what is going guys hey
we're big fans and uh give us the hits
baby yeah what are some Impressions you
do it's never too early to play holiday
music and it's never too early to start
thinking about gifts whether it's just
for a friend or the friends of your
pants
two penis in your balls you can make
this season to be jolly with manscaped
their Platinum package has it all the
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and weed
whacker nose and hair ear hair trimmer
no the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and
the weed whacker knows an ear hair
trimmer they feature proprietary
Advanced Skin safe technology to protect
your delicate parts and your holes both
are waterproof so you can shave in the
shower sounds classy to me don't forget
to apply to the for their aluminum Free
Ultra Premium deodorant for that cologne
quality scent on the go manscaped is
even thrown in two free gifts the
manscape boxers and the shed travel bag
the Platinum package 4.0 covers all your
bases from head to toe tell them how to
do it Mark here's what you got to do get
20 off and free shipping with code drunk
at manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com and use code
drunk manscape get your jingle balls
ready for the holidays
hey folks this episode is sponsored by
betterhelp look Adidas dropped Kanye so
did Balenciaga better help should pick
up Kanye he needs it if life came with a
user manual things would be easy for
everyone but it isn't so when it's not
working for you it's normal to feel
stuck navigating a career change a new
relationship or beginning a parent
becoming a parent can make you feel
uncertain therapists are trained to help
you learn productive coping skills which
makes therapy the closest thing you'll
get to a user manual for you we all go
to therapy we all go to the same guy
love him love him it's a game changer
you got me in I'm hooked he knows me too
well I know it's scary we were talking
the other day about a toxic woman and he
goes uh you're not done with her I was
like yes I am because I know how you are
you love it I'm like I was like [ __ ] you
Alan man he's good oh yeah he is good
better help us online there but it off
his video phone and chat therapy
sessions you can chew used to to not see
anyone on camera if that makes you feel
better tell them how to do it fatty as
the world's largest therapy service
better help has Match 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch back to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms
no traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's better
help.com slash drunk
hey we might be drunk is brought to you
by Lucy you're a responsible consumer
and you want a responsible way to
consume your nicotine don't you well if
you're looking for nicotine gum lozenges
or pouches to use nicotine to relax
Focus or just unwind after a long day
there's only one stop you should make
Lucy
I like this stuff the gum tastes great I
prefer the lozenges because you can just
throw them in you're not smacking around
town with the chewing so uh get on it
plus you know
it just tastes good then it gives you a
little jolt that yeah oh yeah it gives
you a kick if if I'm hungover I pop one
of those in and I'm like
pretty good so the least healthy
endorsement of all time also if you're
going to the casino hitting the slots
just chew the gum and you get the same
the nicotine without having to kill your
lungs so you've been looking for an
alternative to smoking why not switch
the nicotine product that can actually
make you feel good and feel good about
doing it tell them half fatty if you
enjoy using nicotine you should
definitely check out Lucy's products at
lucy.co that's lucy.co promo code drunk
at checkout also I have to read this
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code drunk here here
who are you best at someone we've all
heard of who's your best something
mainstream
um
all right
hey
I was in the movie snatches when it's
not something too small
um
Francisco has a cocaine problem
[Laughter]
one more one more one more
one more one more
one more figure it out sorry I don't
know dude um
[Music]
we put you on the spot we'll put you on
the spot we love you Evan we're
promoting you we love you Evan check
them out on Instagram and Tick Tock this
Tick Tock is so good wait scroll down so
I do a perfect Evan Williams so you'll
see that one Matteo does Evan sketches
and I just do all of his squash
whoa turn up the V2 is so easy
yes it is just showing off his biceps
here yeah huge if you wanted to
um
did you ever see his Mad Lib things no
oh my they're great
this is all
this is all Evan Williams [ __ ] by the
way he directs everything writes
everything right yeah yeah we can turn
me off I'm sorry no it's [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] incredible what he does I love
it
hahaha
[Laughter]
[Music]
I hate you
[Music]
all right that's great and you just came
out
um
he's high he's a hot guy he's so hot in
every game oh my God I can totally
directed her because the last shot was
him like this shredded yeah showing off
the veins in his arms got the guns for
sure that's so funny Mad Libs are
hilarious no dude he's he's yeah
excellent I mean he's had a good comment
yeah he is a really good you just do the
row with you at all we do we just did uh
that cafeteria together
legendary club and I get there and they
go oh this is our temporary Club I go
excuse me and they go yeah I walk in
it's a cafeteria what and they didn't
tell me or my agent or my tour agent
I was
losing could you get that I called you
oh yeah remember I called you in a panic
I was like yeah that's right Sam am I
being a diva or is this incredibly rude
because I sold out am I being a diva or
is performing in the cafeteria
yeah can you imagine though I'm like I
can't even believe I should have walked
out but everyone paid for comedians are
so much more low maintenance and can you
imagine can imagine if like a singer was
like you're in a you're in a cafe yeah
you're at the DMV tonight although they
probably got similar [ __ ] honestly maybe
prop no I don't know I don't think
starting out as a musician has got to be
pretty rough yeah I guess that's true
although you're not starting out you've
been you sold it yeah exactly so did
your fans show up to it oh yeah it was
sold out I Rose to the place every show
was spent like did you give me sloppy
joes yeah here's your sloppy Joe was it
hard with the school bell going on yeah
kids moving running around
everyone's like keep it down I did a
cafeteria once me too at a college yeah
me too University of Delaware oh damn
Tommy pucciani who's now a [ __ ] agent
he's in agent now at William Morris he
reps like Phil and Joe list a lot of
comics we're friends with oh he was a
University of Delaware kid and he booked
me how long ago it was he saw me open
for Jim Florentine in like 2000. wow and
he was like I gotta get you in my school
so he's the only Morris I'm like oh he's
like a legit fan he really is uh but he
booked me and I brought Chris to Stefano
with me yeah and we performed in a
[ __ ] cafeteria oh and Christmas when
Bieber the whole [ __ ] ride I want to
kill him I [ __ ] love him I he I I
think he's great I like
um is it a funny thing about back in the
day like I moved to New York 10 years
ago exactly 10 years ago September 2012
or and it's just so funny like all the
open mics were like you you Michelle
wolf yeah Michael J Michael J like all
these but you you Rose up quick I feel
like you you had a talent you had a an
it you could sing you were confident you
were comfortable on stage I will say
when you're a good performer you can
make up for other shortcomings
it was a quick rise because I was
different doing but then it was like I
had to play catch up I had to really
learn how to write jokes and be taken
seriously and so there was a big dip and
I just spent all that time writing and
writing and writing and writing and
writing and then it slowly you know it
was I've always just kind of okay and
then the last year I just started
putting everything online and then it
just like erupted sure how long did I
tell you to [ __ ] do that for you you
know what though it came at the right
everything happens at the right time you
know and I because I had this hour that
a year ago that I was trying to sell to
streamers and everyone said no and so I
then Schultz was like just cut it up and
put it online and then a year later I've
done that and it's like okay doing the
beacon there you go wow really it's
holding around whoa when is it March 2nd
love it dude excited Jesus congrats man
thanks but I still can't sell a special
ah well but it's okay so why do you want
to sell a special to sell tickets
a lot of people will just go off and
that's short money it is short money and
I do think too like I really like being
a comedian and and I never pull the gay
card but there is a I'm doing a it's a
little bit of a battle to be taken
seriously because I think people think
well he's talking about being gay this
is a uh he's that's a clutch or whatever
you know what I mean like he's using
this but like I have to really because
that's your life right I'm at the
balance like I also date and I you know
like so how do I myself I think that
people do it similarly with women when
they dismiss them as dirty and I'm like
no one says that [ __ ] about men that's
true I do think I do I mean if they're
criticizing you for being gay it's like
well that's your [ __ ] life where you
get both I mean a recent criticism was
uh you know we want to hear more about
your personal life and not about
arbitrary things and I'm like but I also
and it's just such a weird balance that
a lot of people don't that I think women
have to go through anyone who's sort of
marginalized kind of has to sort of
figure out like yeah how do I how do I
do this in a way that I'm getting
respect and also showing that I'm a good
writer it's it's still challenging yeah
but but it should be challenging it is
and I enjoy the challenge and I and I
you know recently was offered a TV role
and I said no to it because it would
have I would have had to cancel my
entire tour and uh what was the rule uh
it was you know like a gay character and
it was a fantastic role in the show but
I said you know I was like I take
stand-up really seriously like I don't
look at like the TV thing is more
important and then I'll get this like I
view stand up in my mind just as
important as anything else so yeah to me
I was like I bet you're making more
money on the road than you are from the
show
that's what I mean so it's kind of like
it's less I bought this new hair
it looks great
this is this is my old hair the new
hasn't come in yet but this is is a
sculpture Michelangelo would blush at
and uh but like you the hair is taking a
while to come out
no my hair I was I came out way earlier
than I am I did not take me four months
to come up so wait what's it gonna be
like because it looks full right now
okay so right now I have it pulled
forward yeah and then I have to
straighten it because I have really
curly hair and then exactly like marks
really it's the exact same yeah yeah
yeah
but once like grows out I'll show you
um but I have a really bad widows like
really pulled back and I was losing my
Widow as well
a Widow's Peak is that everything's in
the front yeah but it comes down like
this oh I see something and in the crown
too and so I just kind of masked that I
use a topic spray and hairspray but then
it's like avoiding wind avoiding pools
avoiding anything you know any oh my God
just horrifying I just don't see you
till April right I'm good so then I
found a really good doctor in New York
and um I went to him and he he uh he
asked a bunch of questions I'm writing
all these bits about it now but one of
his questions
was he goes uh was there balling in your
family and said no he was like your dad
nope he's a brother yeah balding nope he
goes what about your mom's dad and I
said he uh was a Mexican with a one-inch
forehead
like my grandpa Mexican Grandpa's
hairline started there he's got a two
head literally so you know but I can
show you the picture I don't want to
show them I can show you the picture you
want to see when I got the it's fun I
did show you that's right is it with the
bandage and stuff no I didn't get to do
because I saw you right after that's
where they put the hair you can see like
you can see where my normal hairline is
yeah he does a good job a day after the
surgery holy [ __ ] but the the see where
they put the hair wow yeah and then it
falls out the hair they put in takes 10
days to lock in and it's such a [ __ ]
process ice your head sleep like this
spray that yeah and then after 10 days
you can resume your life okay
and shave my head or anything so um wow
but it come in four months you start to
see the results and by a year it's like
are you excited I it's like a gift from
that's my Christmas present yeah I'm
excited to watch the whole thing go down
I know you will it's gonna be exciting
this guy's the limit what is Christmas
your favorite holiday
um yeah I think I think so what's yours
Mark uh well I was Thanksgiving to you
guys trashed it
you know what I like Mardi Gras but I
still like saying I do look I I trashed
the turkey the ritual is very American I
respect that I just love Chinese food I
like Chinese food too but you can have
that on Christmas I do have it on
Christmas let us have the turkey I will
honestly say it's gonna sound weird
coming from a Jew but I [ __ ] love
Christmas because because Christmas is
now it's not even like a who gives a
[ __ ] about Jesus it's about like the
music and the lights and the food
religions this is what I do on Christmas
I order Chinese food and I watch
basketball for 12 hours
well and the night the cellar it's great
uh I thought you love balls and
traveling
it's not a traveling part but the balls
I do enjoy
Italy I love it you're right you're
right love I had a good date last week
too oh okay I love I love Christmas I
love that time of year too there's
something magical about New York City in
the winter but it hasn't gotten really
bad out yet it's just kind of a little
cold that is nice it's also something
magical about being drunk and leaving a
bar at a bar yeah and the wind just hits
your face I love that [ __ ] yeah and
there's a there's a couple Christmas
lights in the distance the trees at
Rockefeller Center there's a the dirty
Santa with the bell I love the whole
thing I love it I love you I love it I
mean I love that time of year I don't
know I mean Thanksgiving is nice so it
is nice to just be a fan just such a
dumb I don't like Thanksgiving it's just
like it's like a shitty foreplay to
Christmas like just get I know but it
starts the insanity it leads us it
leaves some music to Thanksgiving okay
and you don't get sick of Christmas
music they're playing every day well you
like Mariah so that's that's a lock oh
my God she made eight jillion dollars on
that song she wrote that song in a Casio
Keyboard no in less than a day she
writes all around music pull up how much
she made on that I mean because just the
residuals alone has got to be more than
Elon
damn but yeah
he's done a good job she really looks
good she looks great she's still hot I
think I jerked off to a poster of her
and she had roller skates on in some
video and like short jean shorts and I
remember fantasy that I jerked off to a
still photo of that wow back in the day
Sears catalog
the underwear guys how many kids did
Nick Cannon have with her just two they
had twins oh okay all right she seems
like a good mom too how many kids does
she have totally oh yeah Cannon dumped
the load and kept on moving that's right
yeah that's all I want for Christmas
that's better but yeah I think I'm gonna
she's coming to alimony she's [ __ ]
he's getting the alimony yeah good point
I think I think she's coming to uh
Madison Square Garden oh you going yeah
but I've been to her Christmas show nine
times wow she should she'll probably
hear this she won't yeah you're right
I did meet her once really yeah because
the the
um there's a there used to be showing
MTV where like they're your biggest the
fans would be surprised on an elevator
by their favorite celebrity so like
people be on an elevator then Backstreet
Boys just walk in or whatever oh that's
fun I got a call from Stucky who was a
producer at Guy Code and he's like Mateo
we got all surprised for you but I can't
tell you what it is I just need you to
be at MTV I said I know it's Mariah he
goes God damn it boys he knows who it is
so they had me go there the elevator
doors open and there she was wow she was
well well lit and nervous as I imagined
her and I sat on an elevator with her
and fans and her makeup artist for like
probably 15 minutes and we all sing
always be my baby
um I was on her good side so she
couldn't quite look at me uh she was lit
and her every once in a while I had no
doubt she was lit no she was she seems
very sober and together but every once
in a while a hand with a brush would
come come out and just like paint her
face and then like curl back into it and
um this was very nice and everyone's
freaking out I think because we're
Comics we're used to Adrenaline right so
I was quite comfortable and she had just
been in tour in China so everyone's like
if it's gonna I was like oh I was your
tour in China she was like fine you know
like she did yeah she hugged me like I
was the help but um she was great she
did a whistle tone that's a good guess
they did a show with me it would be like
me and Elliott Gould an elevator it
wouldn't be as exciting hold on Sam we
got Leonard Cohn
20 years ago about any Dangerfield
[Music]
what do you think it was like one-on-one
Dangerfield yeah that's so fun I think
he's depressed depressed but I bet the
highs were great and the lows were dark
bathrobe hooker balls out balls out weed
booze enough about me
so stupid good cupcake really seems so
good it's elevator I'll tell you it's
got its ups and downs did you guys try
the Oreo yet or not because that's the
only thing I like this is the best one
for me I don't like Oreos give me an
Oreo try the Oreo because at least it's
got like a kind of saltiness to it too
is it all pump ooh look at that
hmm it's all right yeah you're gonna
have the cookie part of it
you need both trying I'd like to dip it
in uh maybe an eggnog
yeah it's pretty good it's right with
the it's not bad I'm just sick of
pumpkin already I'm done I'm not good
after today I mean this is enough I want
to I want to beat this should I have a
pumpkin yeah let's get a baseball bat
and [ __ ] break a pumpkin on Halloween
you want to do that sure let's do it
tonight you guys car pumpkins is here no
I bought a few and put them on the uh
the stoop oh you bought a place yeah you
guys bought a place you move in yet no
it's a long story we're suing our
contract there and he tried to screw us
it's a whole thing the place is still
dilapidated but are you still keeping
your apartment and where we are probably
not okay you think I should
you could rent it out to people make a
lot of money it's a really good location
yeah I might do that yeah but I did that
first and we had out of this cute nice
Asian lady and the whole building hated
her and they're like you got to get rid
of her the board damn you know the board
it's all these stuffy old dealers I
[ __ ] hate boards hate a board oh my
God there's a woman in my building you
know we got a lot of old Jews in my
building this woman it's like I do are
you allowed to have a trainer in here I
said yeah we ran it up the ladder it's
all fine I got doctors forms they're
stuffy but having trainers in the gym I
know and they go well I'm on the gym
comedian I go excuse me well look at you
the gym committee and my trainers
laughing because I mean I'm just mocking
I'm like the gym committee you're so fat
what did it take to get on there nothing
yeah let me see your six-pack so we
[ __ ] oh she's gonna train her with
her it's a [ __ ] it's Madness there's
another guy who's rude as hell he's rude
to my [ __ ] trainer old man uh he goes
I want to use the bench with it you can
use in a minute we're almost done and he
goes well I've been waiting I said was
the first you said of it and he goes
he's just being so rude and I was like
hey man uh you know there's a way to
talk to people we're speaking
respectfully to you and then and then he
goes well you know I'm having a bad day
go I don't care right yeah I don't give
a [ __ ] about your day and then finally
goes I've already apologized three times
I was like you haven't apologized once
right in his head he thought he did it
funny like when when normal pedestrians
come up to comics and like we already
have 50 yeah
no you're never gonna win this oh my God
I was like literally thinking a roast
jokes while I'm looking around like
you're [ __ ] old you're a loser I'm
like I'm like sizing myself
oh yeah yeah not jokes I'm like you're
gonna be dead soon like that's not a
joke I've been waiting yeah yeah so is
God coming up there but yeah I hate that
[ __ ] and also you're like I could attack
your appearance but I'm I'm being nice
you know I couldn't disintegrate so I
said I could say that you're going to be
dead soon but I'm not that's not the
type of person I am Joan Rivers had one
of my favorite jokes where she was like
I hate old people because old people if
you're if you're here get out I don't
want to see you and I hate old people
that buy at Costco like you're buying 18
jars of large mayonnaise unless God
likes sandwiches you are an [ __ ] it's
like good one Joan uh we love we have
Joan on the wall behind you yeah she's
my favorite comedian of all time yeah
comedy really yeah because I I the first
by the I first got into common with
Kathy Griffin sure because I mean not to
sound so sad but it's like comedy wasn't
really for gay people because there's no
specials on Bravo that's what I'm saying
is like she was the first person I
remember in my entire life ever speaking
positively about gay people in a funny
way like she still roasted us but in a
way that I knew was accepted I was so
internalized for you guys I remember
thinking to myself she shouldn't do that
she'll lose her career wow that's how
internalized my homophobia was and she
made it like she was the first person in
my life I was 16 that I ever heard say
anything positive ever about gay people
she didn't lose her career but it was
over something completely unrelated I
know but then I saw Joan and because
because she did some special on Bravo
when I was in college and I was like
Kathy was already sort of lauded as like
the new Joan Rivers
pencils down yeah hands like this and I
thought I want to be a comedian it's
just joke joke joke joke and she come
out of that stage she's she's like you
know one of the greats Mount Rushmore
right recently she got interviewed she
was one of his favorite communities
she was done Dirty by Carson I thought
that was pretty fun too I think the fact
that if you don't know I mean she was
she was a regular guest host when Carson
sat out and uh she was very popular and
then she was told she would not get the
show she was told by that when Carson's
done it's not going to you're not on the
list and she got a show a late night
show and Carson basically was like
you're done told every show not to book
her really [ __ ] up and her husband
committed suicide her husband did oh
yeah right because of her show where he
was getting into arguments with the
producers at the show when she lost the
show he committed suicide wow she was a
tough person and I used to watch her
first of all I watched the D list I so
much I love comedy great that was a
great show she had the fat husband that
was fun but uh Joan on she made red
carpet bearable oh yeah for a guy like
me I'm watching the red car and she was
merciless with the what are you wearing
oh wow
Ricky Gervais right yeah like the way
Ricky was kind of mean as celebrities
Joan
Keith has where like she can I play a 30
second clip of Joan please do you want
us to play it on the thing type in Joan
Rivers red carpet Anna Nicole Smith
speaking of crutches Keith as a crutch
and speaking of d-list those titties
don't lie all right folks all right
what you're about to hear
um no it has it's a 30 like a you go to
YouTube actually
Joan Rivers Anna Nicole Smith that's
like oh this is cocktails are [ __ ]
money
what she says you could never there it
is
never ever ever say this today
publicity claiming to be the father and
now Lance Bass has come out claiming to
be the real mother I mean just
continuing and the authority author say
they have found no drugs in her system
just a lot of sperm ah wow
has continued to run her ads claiming
that in the last two weeks alone Anna
Nicole has lost yet another 70 pounds
Ah that's great a lot of balls the balls
you can't say no
I mean essentially and you know I can't
be sincere TV viewers even in death
everyone in Anna Nicole's families
trying to make money off of her so they
can buy new sets of tires for their
trailer
oh damn wow good news I would like to
end this monologue on that Andy
Griffin's still on
then married
wow imagine wow imagine saying that
today I mean that would be lose your
sponsors you lose your network the whole
thing she lost so much she didn't give a
[ __ ] yeah what are you gonna do to me
when you were punished like that I mean
but that was comedy that was gold we I
mean you could never do that now they
would cut the whole show like we're
going for the Indian Head and the the
whole you know
what was that thing called you know what
I'm talking about yeah yeah okay I don't
know the name of it but yeah that's just
a different time yeah it's just a
different she gives it from completely a
different era you know Phyllis Dillard
did 20 minutes of how fat her
mother-in-law was right 20 minutes of it
yeah it was just fat jokes
it was a different time well you
different times you didn't have social
media able to write in immediately going
that was Despicable that was
unacceptable you know and to be fair she
wanted the point well the point Joan
said that because she was she meant it
to be mean and she meant it to be
despicable that was the goal yeah um
exactly there's something I mean
obviously I you know the comedy's
changed a lot but I watched that in the
same way I watched like you know I don't
know like a great painting or something
that defined a certain time were you
watch it and think okay this wouldn't
stand for today but it is cool to see
like how Monumental she was in comedy
and like the fact that she was able she
was a she was able to do that it's just
so badass badass I completely agree yeah
I always love that Liechtenstein though
where they uh call Kissinger a [ __ ] no
uh
all right but yeah she she was she was
great but I watched you know I would
watch her as a kid and it it would you'd
go oh that was wild oh that was fun but
then you'd move on with your life I
never like stewed on it like Jesus
Christ well you didn't have anywhere to
go with it yeah I guess so you know what
I mean I know it's cool to just go balls
to the wall and just have fun and you
don't sense that she was malicious she
said that she was like fun she was
malicious but it didn't feel that way
still no as mean as she was it didn't
feel me I think it felt it's kind of
silly I think she was crazy looking that
add that helps if you look like that
would be an insult comic if you don't
look like Don Rickles or Jeff Ross yeah
yeah I think too it's like I think you
could hear like she's mastered her voice
so much right the way she speaks like
she's saying this like I hey I get it
you know what I mean like yeah you know
because sometimes you hear people say
mean things you're like
right it's like why is Keith Keith gets
away with saying the words [ __ ] but it's
like oh yeah he's a good guy
is a good guy it matters when you do
that type of Comedy that people can
sense you're not an actual monster and I
think uh with her it probably helped
that she had so much plastic surgery
that they're like well this person
doesn't like herself my face has seen
more knives than a Benihana and then
Dave Dave Letterman was like you don't
look like the Jonah I remember and she
goes I take that as a compliment
yeah I think he nailed it she hates
herself too she's also insecure you guys
would love a lot there's a lot of drag
queens you would love oh another
excellent comedy the ballsiest joke
tellers of all time
or this guy yeah they're the craziest
yeah lady bunny have you ever seen lady
bunny
can you real would you mind if I do this
I'll read my tickets
[ __ ] hanging out this Thanksgiving
dinner bro oh yeah
uh Okay click on uh
uh yeah you can click on the first one
if you want to this is so lady bunny we
have pause real quick is Lady bunny
still cooking is she she's so good oh
yeah she's a DJ you know she's been
around forever what she does is she
writes all of her own jokes records her
jokes and then lip syncs her jokes and
then adds a beat in between it so
between each insult she's an insult
comic she does a damn oh wow this is
this is warning you now if you're
triggered you'll be triggered I can't
wait listen folks if you're triggered
it's like Bernie Mac I ain't scaredy
[ __ ]
okay okay
hi my name is Lady Bunny and my
preferred pronouns are [ __ ] and sugar
tears
some are really cheesy and then some are
like the best jokes okay I said I'm not
sure if I'm a man or a woman he said
just pull your pants down I said no no
he said you're a woman
that's clever it's a great great joke
my name is
where is it is this New York yeah
at this point Caitlyn must have the
Spotless [ __ ] in the family too bad
she's also the biggest [ __ ]
I love it you showed that women who
sleep better have better sex
unfortunately the study was conducted by
Bill Cosby
ah it's great that's a great joke
is hashtag metoo hashtag time's up and
don't forget my movement hashtag where's
my
ah I love to pull the pants down dude
I've got skin tags
that's a [ __ ] dad joke though yeah
they make the phone so small these days
I mean it's so I'm having a blast oh
this is real New York yes
that's a great pun it's weird that it's
like an offensive dad joke right it's
like
I don't want to be cremated
we don't have to we can move that's fun
I like it
pull your pants to one as a killer Lanzo
is a Cosby one [ __ ] she is stuff I love
that's that is real drag yes that's real
drag New York drag and you'll see Lady
bunny everywhere and sometimes I don't
know she's DJs at the monster in the
West Village on every Sunday night but
um every time I run into her I never
remember she's gonna remember me or not
remember me it's because she's like wild
yeah she's a legend lady Bunny's Legend
writes all her own jokes does songs
writes all her own songs she like does
song parodies where like once just
Richard she did a duet with Richard
Gere's Mouse in her ass so she's like
singing a duet with him and like she
just like she and she does long
interviews about like political
correctness and what that means and what
like you know she's she's really smart
really fascinating and and um has she
been and you know gotten in hot water at
all and well she didn't kicked off
Twitter but then everyone voted to get
her back on Twitter so we got we got
lady bunny back on oh yeah we need her
because she's she's uh she's like kind
of a perfect example of someone who's
like she survived the AIDS pandemic she
survived homophobia she survived like
everything and she's coming out just
still doing her she's she's a legend
it's like fun New York energy yes do you
remember lucky Chang's did you ever go
there yeah it was of course yeah it was
on uh First Avenue or Second Avenue
Lower East Side yeah East Village area
it's gone now the drag bar yeah yeah I
did shows there all the time then drag
queens would come on after you and I was
I thought I was edgy then they would go
on I was like Jesus Christ like just
that it was Bianca Del Rio Bob the drag
queen uh Trixie Mattel great joke yes
really great joke writers wow I love it
good stuff how's the drag
that's fun man it's that's also too like
it's fun I think that helped fun jokes
that walk that line is like a smile
silliness like this type of [ __ ] where
there's me I mean just showing that
you're not a [ __ ] monster I mean a
lot of it's presentation like gift
wrapping attention for sure what's the
intention well we've lost that vloggers
never [ __ ] taking the time exactly I
got canceled once I did that comedy
seller show I have a whole bit about
this but um
trying to think about how much I can get
into without ruining my bed the news
show where you do the news headlines we
get to sell let's figure this out yeah
and one of them was the the type the
subject was Mike Pence and so I was like
I'm gay I'll cover that one and um I did
a whole joke about how he wants to jail
gaze and you know they'd if they sent us
to jail I'd be like you want to put me
an island with a bunch of gays I'll come
and I'll come we'll just reenact all the
musical scenes from Chicago you know and
uh this and before people put stuff up
online by the way they gave us a day to
write those jokes I know right it takes
six months sometimes of course of course
so I put it on you don't care and you
don't give a [ __ ] about that I was just
trying to eat right so you're right they
paid well they gave us the stuff and I
put it on my Twitter which I don't have
anymore and uh uh this gay blogger got
wind of it and said Mateo Lane is
dangerous to the gay community and and
promotes gay men going to jail and I was
like what promotes I was like what or
supports in The Game Jesus Christ I know
it was crazy and then like thousands of
tweets like you monster I tell you like
what about Uganda I was like what about
Uganda
like how did we get to you guys are
bringing up separate stuff yeah I'm
talking about Mike Pence you know like
and also two like my the point of the
joke was the target audience of Comedy
Central at the time was white men 18 to
35. so I was like all right I'm gay I'll
let them know Mike Pence doesn't like
gay people that was the point of the job
the intention of the joke was to like
tell people about how destructive he is
and they spun it and they spun it for
themselves let's say like that's how
they get eyeballs and they're the good
guys
they are trying to make their name in a
way that's trying to destroy you like
yeah
is all they care about right because
they they use someone who grows who
actually has to put themselves in front
of people right and then say you know
but I mean it was kind of a good
experience these people never get
dragged the way we do no drag queens
who are like trying to to go after you
but you're like none of your [ __ ] is out
there you don't have to deal with any
backlash no all of our [ __ ] is out there
yeah and we're trying to get laughs
we're trying to with that look I mean
that's the deal that's Patrice said
Patrice was like the jokes you like and
the jokes you don't like came from the
same place yeah yeah well Emma I'm not
I've had disagreements I don't like
everyone's job they're allowed to
dislike it but when you try to drag us
and try to take out of context what we
said for your own gain you're a [ __ ]
pig you're a piece of [ __ ] you're the
monster your masking and our [ __ ] it's
all out there and their [ __ ] isn't and
it's not in that way it's not a fair
fight but at the same measure we will
usually have a bigger following than
they do because yeah because we earned
it by putting that [ __ ] out there people
read like Keith always says people see
[ __ ] and so like I think like you
know for me it wasn't a bad experience
at the time I was it was a nightmare
because I didn't experience that I also
had no followers like I was I was just
trying like a comic you know and um but
but I got to see what was like I got to
see what it's like for everyone to hate
you and to misconstrue what you say and
yeah and um it hurts it it hurts but In
fairness I was like you know what that's
his gig and how I react to it is what he
says is not my problem it's how I react
to it which is such a kind of gross
thing to say mature very mature so you
know and now I'm using it as a bit I'm
talking about stage and you have a bit
about a person who's right to cancel me
in 2013 right now that's hidden pretty
that's when I met you I met you eating a
burrito at the cellar and or at uh the
creek in the cave while you were going
through that uh do you remember that oh
yeah and I came up to and I said I I
never met you before but that's why I
first met you my very vivid memory and I
was like I'm sorry like what you're
going through and you're like ah you
know like you were very Sam about you're
like yeah you know it sucks what are you
gonna do that's a [ __ ] they don't get
it and you're just like going into this
burrito I was just an open mic some
things never change yeah yeah no uh but
at the same time it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] the world where's the hot sauce
um no it was it happens to you and it's
a good taste it really is I mean yeah
because it shows you what a lot of
people's intentions are and because our
intention I get it look I've I've even
had podcasts where we argue with each
other and stuff like that you know I'm
certainly not Mr PC and don't want to
tell anyone what to say but there's also
times I'm like where we have to
distinguish what a joke sure because
just saying words doesn't make it a joke
yeah but that's a whole other topic I
think generally speaking all Comics uh
are just trying to just trying to make
people happy at the end of the day make
light of things dark things if you have
a school shooting joke I did a joke in a
New York comedy club not too long ago
and it was a joke about school shootings
and that's already a dicey topic yes I
have this whole bit about how like a lot
of these guys are in cells they just
need to get laid so we should that's a
whole prostitute bit and a woman's like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you you're promoting sex
trafficking and I'm like promoting I'm
doing a bit about it's a a silly bit
about bringing prostitutes into school
to [ __ ] the weird kid and she's like
[ __ ] you so they're throwing her out and
she's like suck my dick I have it all on
tape but I had some good responses but I
was just like you're so awesome I'm not
a government official yeah
what you're talking about but it was her
moment to your point I think people have
confused everything to be everything
used to be different otherwise a
comedian was a comedian and a politician
was a politician that's right I haven't
gotten [ __ ] before but now anyone with
any kind of platform is viewed equal and
so in a way people have confused because
I'm online we all see the same thing on
one app so whether you're a dog trainer
or a political you know whatever a
politician or a comedian we view you
parallel it's all on the same plane so
we expect you to ever want to have the
same morals but in reality you know
people aren't upset online it's like
this this isn't this isn't a comedy show
so there is a kind of agreement we make
right agreement we've signed a contract
to say I'm sitting here to listen to
what some things that could offend me
but under the agreement that it's funny
because we all know what happens when
you make a joke and everyone laughs in a
comedy club because you've built up
right that you've built up the
environment to show that I'm safe and
you I'm I'm not trying to hurt anybody
right which gets cut out and then thrown
online exactly exactly like like I met
some sort of rally right I'm like I'm at
the hot yes yes oh my literally it was
literally my response to a woman who
just yelled at free Palestine my show
and I go that was fascinating and I was
just like what and she goes I'm trying
to make a point I was like at the Omaha
Funny Bone right exactly I do love that
we're making this we're gonna have this
like you know hardcore common discussion
Mateo's in his gobble gobble gobble
shirt you're in my he's my sweet potato
yeah we're trying to be fun hey you keep
it fun and light I'm with you man I I
think you have to understand we talk
about intent we talk about being silly
we talk about like anyone who gets
really offended at a show it's not about
the joke it's something it's about some
other [ __ ] that happened to you that day
that week maybe that you haven't dealt
with in therapy I can't tell you how
many
people I've you know dealt with in my
life where they're screaming at me I'm
like this isn't how I communicate yes I
go to therapy I've kind of worked on
myself you work on yourself then come
back and we'll have this conversation or
don't I don't want to talk don't work on
yourself I don't give a [ __ ] walk in
front of a bus I could give a [ __ ] I do
feel I mean I don't go quite as dicey in
my I mean you guys really go into
subjects and I it's it's I really admire
it because I don't have the foreign
I've heard gay jokes that I don't like
but I would never think to walk up to
someone and say anything to them I mean
people have asked me about gay jokes and
then I'll if they ask me I'm playing
well you've asked me and I'm guessing
that you want my opinion in my opinion
um but generally speaking I've heard
some gay jokes that are great like your
project I always go back to like the sex
is brutal that's an old Market oh wow
that's all I know but that's one of my
first memories of you right also my
first memory of you was you got Conan
you ran it at the creek open mic and
farted on stage that's my first memory
of Mark my head's my big closer yeah
I got the best comment there was a gay
waiter at the cellar years ago he had
glasses he was a short guy I forgot his
name Darren I can't remember but he got
fired or something any his last day he
goes every comic has gay jokes they do
the gay voice it drives me crazy and you
never did that you have Gage though you
never did the gay boy hello I don't like
I don't like that I don't like it either
and I never did it and he was like that
meant a lot to me and I was like oh
great all right but I never forgot that
I don't like the making the gay dudes
into one guy I never I don't like that
either
or a woman or whatever I don't do a
black voice what am I doing the same why
am I saying doing a gay boy so I was
kind of like I will say as a gay person
it's very fun to do gay boys it's a fun
voice
but I was always kind of like if the
joke doesn't stand on the writing I
don't think it's worth doing right my
joke on gay boys is that it's so funny
because like in my head I sound like
yeah but like in real life like we just
don't know we have gay boys but it's and
you hear your voice back you don't know
well now I know I listen to my sets
every night you know what I mean but
yeah before that I was like that might
sound like Gaston I sound like a tiger
so it's so funny Cody the tiger yeah
that's so funny that's your idea of a
strike I thought he was gonna say like
John Wayne he's like you know the guy
from the series
the drag the horse the role players hey
oh please please yeah
um
clearly was a bottom I um wow you heard
it here first guys you have any gay boys
exists in every language too like in
Italian you can just hear gay voice oh
really
we all have that voice yeah Ah that's
fascinating why is that why does the the
gayness make you sound a certain way now
we're more fun yeah probably more fun
more musical more it's also like a
mating call a little bit right I mean
like you have a different sound well you
have a different sound so you're
attracting people hear you by the way my
brother's also gay he you would never
stereotypically in quotations you just
would never know well Tim Dylan's gay he
doesn't know him doesn't have the gay
voice well Tim is Tim has you have to
listen to what Tim says not how he
sounds because Tim has some of these
funny like quick like oh that only a gay
man could talk about sassy he's got sass
him is really funny yeah he but but he
has that like Long Island voice like
right like I'd work on a truck you know
yeah he prefers a fairy but
but yeah yeah it's funny with gay boys
and it's it is so strange yeah I love it
I used to be so ashamed of it now I I
love Go With It brace it yeah yeah if
you feel happy right now in life because
things are going well for you I feel
it's where the gay used to being happy
back in the day yeah and it's so ironic
because no gays are happy we're just
especially not New Yorkers New Yorkers
are just cranky [ __ ] but is there a
better place to be gay than New York
you get the hottest guys but you only
see them once for three minutes it's
over and then everyone's rude to each
other but then you have great but I
don't know yeah the bodies the six packs
my life is so I I quite I have a bit of
a like
um I I don't live that life and I I
sometimes feel left out like I see all
these gays and getting even costumes and
going out to parties and doing these new
like dancing and stuff going comedy I'm
so my I'm my I'm just so knee deep into
comedy like that I don't get me wrong I
love it's if I walk into a club I feel
I'm being judged by my looks if I walk
into the cellar I know I'm being
appreciated by my intellect and I I love
the seller so I don't ever look back and
regret it because you know I I don't
have to the problem is we're sick of
proving ourselves we're sick of trying
because as a comic you prove yourself
for so many years and you just walk into
the cellar and you're instantly accepted
yeah you know you go on these dates and
it's like dazzle me you're like
I'm tired so I think that's kind of why
we love the comedy seller in the comedy
family I mean you know I think about
Steve you know who he just lost that's
just absolutely tragic and it's like it
is weird how hard
like comedy he's the head of security
the comedy teller just passed away it's
weird how hard
comedy family deaths hit you well you're
like I would think I'd say I was like
man I'm really [ __ ] sad yeah yeah
that was I see him every time I go to
the South every I have a show at them
you shake hands every night we're silly
together you have that kind of weird
because you have so much time to kill
together so you just have to create this
silly relationship yeah and he was like
the antithesis of a bouncer he was like
super intellectual super well read he
took he took photos did you ever see him
with his camera oh yeah he was like
brilliant guy and then he's like this
bouncer guy super warm super friendly
you'd always say whenever I wear like a
tank top he's like Mateo why are you out
here making all of us look bad
yeah big hugs good to see you how are
you yeah it's it's really quite he and
also he when he because sometimes he
used to be at McDougall he's been at
Village Underground more recently but I
mean Google he loved watching Comics
sets yes and knew our jokes and knew we
were working on new stuff yes it was
like that kind of stuff I [ __ ] love
and hated a few guys by the way yeah
which also means he was watching which
also meant he was a part of the company
yeah like gossiping I got into it with a
guy on the sidewalk outside of the
cellar you know a guy was like you know
there's just Rando weird guys that's
walking around and this guy was giving
me [ __ ] and I was walking towards the
cellar go to a spot and I just had
enough I was having a bad day like your
old tenant and I was like you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] and we started going at it and
this guy would have killed me Sean
Patton walks up he shows me his knife
like if anything goes down I'll stab
this one Sean Patton is just a pirate
he's a pirate he's a fat pirate he
should have a parrot like right here
yeah
yeah and uh I was like kind of backing
up and the guy was like coming towards
me but I knew I had Steve there yeah and
that's all I needed because like even
this guy beat the [ __ ] out of me Steve
would just pick him up like this oh my
God they protect us they protected us we
run our mouths yeah the guy like oh you
got a problem yeah check out this guy he
got between us and he was like get the
[ __ ] out of here and the guy was like
whoa okay there's another seller bastard
saw some guy I gotta know with a guy out
there because it's Madness down there
it's Madness and he had a [ __ ] weapon
on him and I was like hell yeah dude
just knowing he had that you do get
cocky yeah
not not a dangerous weapon but enough
what are we talking pistols AK-47
Raphael
that's yum chuck oh is that a Ninja
Turtle I don't know if that was your ex
[Laughter]
wow a nunchuck that's always a weird
sign that's the only thing I love about
the seller is like you know we're I
think we're all lucky enough to be like
working there for a long time yeah it
really just just feel like a home it's
very nice you get to go in and catch up
and you know I go in less if it wasn't
so [ __ ] fun and other clubs are good
but it doesn't have the same Vibe the
seller's completely different I love
walking in and seeing how a mad Liz is
at me every night yeah yeah manager the
seller she's always mad at me and Liz is
good too because Liz I'm literally the
best summer of my life was June July and
August of 2020 because
um I got a new apartment near the cellar
near near our home oh yeah and um it was
like it was kind of a strange time
because no one was working there's no
fomo everyone had left New York and the
only people that were there was Jose and
Liz yeah at 12 o'clock they open I go
downstairs and I would leave at eight
o'clock yeah Garden we'd figure out what
are we eating for dinner tonight we hang
out in the street like it's the 1970s
and yeah and it was and then the next
summer when everything came back me Liz
and Jose all text each other like oh I'm
gonna miss that was like such a special
time yeah we would cook in the cellar
kitchen and make dinner and invite Keith
and like set out a table wow I'll eat it
was that's great fantastic it was weird
that the community that fomo was was
weird I mean I think about that with my
ex like we would just cook dinner every
night and it was like you know I do miss
that weird like nothing brings you
together like that just movies and and
pajamas dinner and pajamas and desserts
and not and not having gigs to go on
every weekend so yeah oh [ __ ] we're
we're being together right it's like a
family this is actual togetherness right
oh maybe we should take time off
we're not healthy or happy no no I do
feel happy I remember
I have one moment do you have a moment
in your life where you realize the life
I'm living is not what I want I'm
missing out on something yes because I
was a whole childhood
basically decided me to laugh you know
no no no this is your delivery
um I was
it's not the journal
DiGiorno do you know what that means no
of of the day
um of the day of the day oh okay but um
I remember I was at like uh in Michigan
in the winter my friend got a cabin and
all my friends went up my friends I grew
up in Chicago and and I love them but
everyone was drinking and just and I
remember laying in bed really depressed
and was like I just don't that was like
24. I was like I just don't think this
is what I want and then the second I
started doing comedy and never looked
back
no I'm back same here I would get
blackout drunk to hang out with my
friends and I didn't think that was
weird because we all just drank so much
we were like degenerate pieces of [ __ ]
kids but then when you found comedy
you're like oh I have a goal I have
something to work towards I have a bit
to write I have a show tonight what do
you think about where we started how
many people just peeled off I know a few
well you have to wait yeah it wasn't
meant for them yeah yeah and also I
think like man how many degenerate
pieces of [ __ ] we drink with now so
we've grown but at least we have
something common we have something in
common and it's easy and and you find
that's the thing if you're young and you
haven't found your group yet you'll find
your group yeah yeah you'll find your
people and keep looking and keep looking
don't settle for people that you don't
connect with because your people are out
there and uh if you're thinking about
Isis that might be for you yeah that's
what I'm saying still a group my gay
crew uh Bob the drag queen exchange my
friend Nick all very similar drag queens
are very similar to comedians very
simple same life writing jokes getting
on stage dealing with [ __ ] something
that bonds you with other people in a
very specific type of performance yes so
when I'm with drag queens like my
friends Bob Monet and I feel very much
like I'm with comedians yeah I want to
meet these drag queens oh my god let's
all let's all go out for uh I would love
to Great bring us with you and plug
dates man there's been a yes oh my God
sorry yeah I hope I wasn't long-winded
oh there's no dates right there uh We've
added a bunch of shows guys are one of
my favorites great clubs sold out you
love to see that sold out I know most of
my that's yeah all right he's at the
Pittsburgh improv in December you know
what I'm doing I'm uh uh I'm at the
um Cincinnati Funny Bone in January
stand up live Phoenix Arizona oh that's
a big one show left so if you want to
come that's November 18th and 19th and
then I'm going on a theater tour Queen
Elizabeth Theater February 9th and 10th
added our third show Ace theater
downtown Los Angeles added second show
Neptune Theater added our fourth show oh
yeah Palace and Fine Arts San Francisco
and then Beacon New York all right I
love Toronto that's gonna be fun all
right okay yeah what do we what day is
this Matt God Mark your schedule aren't
you [ __ ] tired I'm wiped I'm wiped
I'm [ __ ] blood how do you look so
good and this is your schedule
ah you know black don't crack joint
theater in New Orleans the will where we
got a fourth show at the Wilbur College
Street Music Hall in New Haven uh
Fillmore and Philly uh helium Buffalo
uh Cobbs Comedy Club always wanted to do
it zany's in Nashville the Blue Note oh
yeah that'll be fun and yeah
marknomahcomedy.com for dates thank you
hey we got uh Springfield Missouri uh
Fort Wayne Indiana oof uh Kansas City
Missouri Tacoma Spokane Oklahoma make
update I'm sorry about that then the
theater tour starts New Orleans Austin
Dallas Tulsa St Louis Vegas baby
Vancouver just added a late show there
uh Seattle Portland Salt Lake City
All-Star Weekend basketball I'm hanging
that week Atlantic City Royal Oak
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee New Haven
Boston I had the Late Show there and
we'll hopefully add more there Miami
Orlando Jacksonville Atlanta Charleston
Durham Charlottesville Virginia D.C all
this [ __ ] uh Wilkes-Barre PA and Port
Chester yeah bro oh really really YES
tour bus baby let's [ __ ] go meters on
there oh little Gary's gonna be getting
[ __ ] tortured on that bus I taught
Gary how to make a coffee oh dude we're
gonna have a great time and uh get
Bodega cat whiskey the best whiskey in
the business Bodega catwhiskey.com
subscribe to this podcast beard you what
do you got going on man did you still at
say less NYC on 38th Street come check
us out we're rolling out the new fall
menus and uh Peter playing NYC for all
your hospitality Consulting needs let me
help you make your restaurant or bar we
love it I mean shout out to Matt Peters
who's been crushing these students
waiting outside
last time Mateo was here Burr went long
and Mateo had to leave and we felt
[ __ ] I was like Bill Burr can do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants I am never
going to tell Bill can you hurry up so I
can talk about Mariah like this is a
great app this is a killer app but in
our defense Bill's like I'll give you an
hour I can do an hour and then he
wouldn't leave because you guys are
great I will [ __ ] hey man we were
grateful to have him thank you so much
for having me on the show you guys no we
love you man we love you we're proud of
you and uh you're you're a buddy I mean
this is a killer app we might be drunk
pod subscribe to the YouTube channel
subscribe everywhere you get this [ __ ]
yeah and uh and drink this [ __ ]
Bodega cat everyone's loving it follow
me on Instagram Mateo lame hot hot funny
the whole package it's on there too we
love it in jeans and uh get on the
patreon get a bodega hell ciao
[Music]
dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
we might
[Music]
foreign